start the stream let's wait for good old
let us know see the game in perspective
and then look his love in there I see
lights says starting on my side says
live or me and we Oh laughs welcome to
the islands podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 144 it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about why you breathing so
hard in the back what's the sitrep as
the carota vitamin and everything the
coronavirus we can raise money that way
a very excited about our special guests
and we've got switch and xbox earning
reports remote play coming to switch and
the impact of Jedi fall in order to
discuss so we go get right into it Wow
JD gamer thank you brother for our super
chat super Jack's words have a great
podcast fellas to hit that like why wow
thank you so much my appreciate it JD
we're gonna have you for the rest of the
day bro I know it sounds like you
leaving I want to introduce a lord of
legality whom the Lords are not only
proud to call a friend to the room but
always provides the most informative get
analytical takes on today's gaming and
pop culture introducing the created host
of virtual legality to hogs are better
than one and the hold law you tube
channel actual shows calls to hogs are
better than right here with a brother
the newest member of the 7k subscriber
club and the only Lord with the audacity
to rekt Mass Effect 2 as the lowest
entry in the Bioware series laugh from
Michigan and breaking his return into
the realm of the Lord's mom man Lord
Richard ho how you doing sir I'm great
happy
Super Bowl Sunday was a good time oh
yeah there was a lot to take using that
introduction you know I only come on
this show for the intro
it's uh yeah yeah I'm gonna have to
answer to some folks about the Mass
Effect 2 thing you talked about that on
Twitter at Lake but yeah you know one
thing I want to say is you know I've
been doing these making brief
appearances with you guys as a fantastic
show this is I don't know four or five
for me maybe six and you guys invited me
on when I had whatever I think I'm about
six to six yeah
Lourdes Cognito invited me on when I had
I don't know eight hundred subscribers
and you know I'd like to say I he's
always been very supportive the iron
Lords have always been very supportive
of virtua legality and whole ah and yeah
we we have seven thousand five hundred
subscribers now and it feels pretty good
we're having good conversations were you
know offending basically everyone and
all political stripes at all times
so I think I think we're doing good work
oh let me tell you it is so cool to see
your growth because like you said I mean
I remember when you first you'll kind of
get gotta say first started but early
the game and yeah absolutely
I'm just like man hope is a beast if
people get to see his talent it's only a
matter test I can I can I can calmly say
i sorry i sorry honestly god you you you
and I were talking on Twitter right
really at the start of it I just wanted
to say I appreciate it I'm looking
forward to a good conversation today but
yeah it's it's really nice to see some
of those folks who have stuck with us
for now a year in a month for that
channel and it's been a lot of fun so
far that's awesome and real quickly Oh
what have you been lately sir I've been
playing the practice of law for the most
part been a very very busy January for
home law which is good news for keeping
the lights on and the family fed but
outside of that I've been mostly playing
on my Nintendo switch I've been diving
back into coffee like like he plays the
switch right back into Fire Emblem
yeah after they announced the expansion
I said oh you know I really should try a
different house so I'm now I'm now the
head of the blue lions and we're going
through it again on now I'm hard because
I'm not I'm not big enough for Matty
pick that up in like six months
chillin with the lady then super bowl
for me fellas
we'll catch you all later remember to
hit the like button but I thought it was
on a Friday
Wow we got oh my man just for all the
members in there for some it's some IOP
emblems in that chat to celebrate our
gold a brand new one that was the the
the squire well it's not the squire
that's actually the an issue of what so
that's cool good salute to the realm for
having that so well let's get this going
unfortunately our Nintendo guru be
please said your thoughts your prayers
to him man he messaged me this morning
from the ER he is not doing well he had
all intention of coming on today he was
ready to go to war with King he told me
he's like King is not gonna be ready for
the switch landed Corona bar we do on
our personal time is none of their
business alright if we if we try to
silence Goro it's hard as it's not
they're definitely they definitely try
to slip something in your ass what I did
was I gave him one of those spiked Funko
pops
[Laughter]
he opened the bag it was like oh that's
what you did I shot him before those
little blow dart things that
well wishes to the Tendo guru I'm on a
road to recovery miss my brother he
would have been a spicier one if he was
here no doubt and we definitely thought
I said I thought so hope he gets back on
the mend and also know for not down a
horse of him Lord soft working the clock
the iron bank definitely uh you know
working really hard so he said he
couldn't make it today but um hopefully
our brother will be back he's the one I
send on the mission and guru now we just
applied another person in this relevant
native baby native has arrived this
morning don't mean it attracted ILP
goodness but I had this year
yo shout out to my bro that he can make
it to eat to be too and song he has to
be there brother
III shout to stitch already fearing the
switch talking who did that for you
everybody said congrats to native that
is what says anyway so we still got the
three awesome bit of gaming of course we
got my caustic almost my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the half
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict a daughter a guy hold up
hold up I got the camera on my what
so I can't even put okay I got you
so I've been playing actually haven't
played the switch at all this week I was
gonna play yesterday about the nerves I
was yesterday what to turn it on and it
was dead and I was like this is it this
is
an issue for another day fine god yes
you know I've been playing a lot of
pretty just destiny too and start do
Valley I've been playing some of that
too it's it's a fun game actually I got
sénéchaux for PC simulator building
simulator that's a different game than I
thought it was like literally you like
you run like a shop that fixes PCs so
it's got like a little story in there
somehow you know it's it's a cool little
thing but it's been an interesting week
because I don't feel like death either
so tell everybody right now that flu is
going around it is real
Oh shot two our brother LM in Tokyo with
the for our super chat you guys always
finish how's my week well so that's
what's up man and I'm gonna peel my man
much love so that's been it for Lord
addict and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this just waiting for
that Kingdom Hearts 3 on xbox aka the XS
gamer
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement Oh beloved
Lord K how you doing sir oh boy I'm
doing fantastic I miss you sovereign go
in on you today pause buddy's guru I'm
sorry I put you down baby another
challenge
I can handle stealth for K I can't
handle self okay Carlito sovereign and
guru so some of them had to leave all
right we got it Cavalry's arrived before
y'all continue alright go check this out
um we have boxing the miami boxing on
dis on this weekend on Thursday instead
of Saturday and Friday the zone is out
of in mind
but it was one fight on that card around
all those amateurs you had really good
fights are fighting and you had Joey
Diaz versus Terran farmer chaplain
farmer has been calling out Javonte tank
Davis for over a year and a half
well he should have had his eyes focused
on Joey Diaz because he was blinking and
breathing hard and looking at that clock
all night Joey Diaz had to cut over his
eye that was the size of a PlayStation 4
controller it was just like this and
that man got that cut stop did they
stopped it his cut man stopped the
bleeding
it was it was huge though it was wide
open it was disgusting to look at but
your man kept parrying kept blocking
shots going to the eye and he beat Tevin
farmer what a gutty performance so shout
out to Joey Diaz if you can see that
fight I'm gonna tell you right now that
is a fight of the Year candidate to me
um and heaping and Javonte take Davis
like on cue like like the comedian he is
jumped on Twitter and said stay in your
lane farmer will David be getting the
baby Yoda slideshow collectible adjust
whatever you're already brought to him
already told them I posted it yesterday
you know I get a little off every time I
tweet out some stuff from sideshow mr.
um Aynsley Bowden my man already you
already sent him my confirmation pic
with my order I definitely had to get
two baby odors
- baby odors are inbound and they should
be here by September I expect that to be
back there rotating baby Yoda looks so
incredible I mean I can get a shot of it
that baby Yoda can handle that our venom
back there if he wanted to
I like that belt of event it was amazing
a great straight job if you know then go
see the video of the venom I think y'all
really need to go check it out please
check it out it's one of the heat see
not look look at that baby Yoda
looks like we can't see it became really
got like lines it's like if you come
down stay you stay on the line you don't
understand is a moat right there the
bottom of the steps where everybody
needs this sanctuary this is my
sanctuary what have you playing Jedi
fallen order I have been turning I have
purchased Jedi fallen order and I am out
of love with this game I'm doing every
little tiny minutia know what I'm doing
is a fourth if you call the girl
assisted the one that's there that
they're actually that's their names okay
don't talk to me but again stop no way
alright anyway I've been playing that
playing children of mortar and um I love
more to a game is so it's it's the best
roguelike for the simple D geeks that
follow order ain't on game pass though
no no it's not Bethany Polly bought a
game outside but see what it is is I
have also have EA access and I told you
my negro bucks came in Michael scoffs
tell me my money
so I went and I purchased jet iphone
another one my negro bucks remember the
dude defrauded me and said I won a game
so when he said I wanna get my jet I
fallen order I said I get a free one
thank the gods and it was not meant to
be but you know what you know what field
I'm gonna smack some expense he said to
me he said you know what I got you came
here's your Negro bucks and go because
he doesn't care West but my money long
as I'm gaming with Xbox so I went went
to EA access I said you did say I get
10% off for all purchases with you guys
right we do I said thank you and then I
purchased it and I downloaded it and I
don't like the pop n dough pop and I'm
waiting for the extra series X so that
pop thing could be a later
I agree with you on that yeah engine
issues okay if you fit I just got to get
to introduce a couple laws that have
joined the realm okay first of all we
got we got we got the Silent One himself
this is a special occasion
Lord stealth 40k I see your mic is muted
hopefully can unmute and we can get your
voice going on it's getting a spirit
bomb together great bro I got yourself
man I haven't smoked this note in a
while and it would be great to hear his
voice but until he comes back
we also have some PlayStation
representation in here my man mr. bad
[ __ ] so to be at PAX East with the last
I'm doing fantastic and you know we were
just talking about you know PlayStation
just a little while ago you said hey
anytime you need a PlayStation voice let
me know five minutes later you like
we all poison guru because I put a
little something in his water
but yeah no you know what I'm happy to
be here guys we're gonna say this so
much this mango listen to the podcast
think we really did poison it he's
looking at all the stuff that these guys
love was any other said Porter from New
York what's going on I got home routine
early right all the statements are said
in jest yeah I guess you saw my DM and
my money oh my god so first and foremost
now venom statute let's all talk about
thank you thank you so yeah I saw that
yes last night I saw that video
oh my god and baby Oda two of ours so
hit me with the email yeah I couldn't
jump on that line fast enough yeah that
money last night I was just like you
know what I did so I graduated college
in December right I'm just like you III
Facebook message my mama's it's like you
know usually people get like your
graduation gift so give me a baby I'm
trying
listen I'm this is how I do a lot of my
outside show stuff when you go on you
purchase now the only thing that you got
to put up right now is $35 B maybe $350
you put a 10% it's $35 and you can do
the payment plan which will probably be
something like what $60 a month until
September when it comes out or maybe $20
a month depends and then when it comes
out in September they ask for the
balance and then you ship so you can
either pay it all up front you can do um
the portions you know
like those the Porsches because I got so
many statues yeah my budget is probably
like 500 $600 a month and portions and
that's it
but do it now because I already know
people's gonna be my father's they're
gonna hit baby 4 we're trying to make it
like it's a family investment like we're
all around us that's what my my goal is
but real talk I've been playing a few
games as I as we wait for stealth first
foremost shout out to Luke Lord the
incipit ghost himself we've been playing
on xbox where's Matt this beautiful
piece of architecture here we've been
playing Star Wars Battlefront 2 I love
that game so much that I went to EA
access on PlayStation I planted that and
so yeah look dude let me tell you
something
Star Wars on a battlefront on the Xbox
one
mm-hmm incredible yes it's so beautiful
I have an ex as well I know on the
PlayStation guy ah yeah I'm awful but
like loved it
I read on that X right yeah Oh most
things do like look like playing The
Witcher goodness gracious yes then what
I decided to do on my show we have a
little something on the trophy we've
caught the road to greatness each and
every month we try to play a game from
the backlog of the history of
PlayStation and so we decided after a
ping up death stranding which one that
was a treat we would be playing
uncharted the loss of legacy I'm charted
I think a lot of people have looked over
I definitely I did I played the first
level it's like this is a Nathan Drake
I'm adding it let me tell you something
guys yeah everybody children of all ages
this is the best Uncharted game real for
real
there's a thing called a good we're not
going to talk about Vita we're not gonna
talk about you know uncharted one which
is man but after those solid games I
think all the insurers and I love all
Uncharted I'm not listening in you attic
I'm sorry
certain games you can now you're not
gonna be besmirching these games I have
you know but uncharted for me it was a
refreshment from the Tomb Raider I mean
it's a little bit different it was like
an action big-budget action movie
uncharted for me was mad that's fair I
like the reasons Inc in the chat that's
trading his garbage this story is for
sure oh we can agree on that
oh I know you about to go in get a bowl
we could agree on the degree on the
district okay we because you know I
value his opinion yeah so you know every
year cop ten countdown of our favorite
games of the year and unfortunately
corporate law intervened and we're stuck
on number five Resident Evil 2 but I
will tell you this in the top four for
my games of the Year 2019 death
stranding is among them and one in my
opinion death stranding was not only
novel and unique in a way that we so
rarely see in triple-a game development
okay it was also affecting and tried to
actually touch some part of the
emotional psyche of human experience
that is also so rarely touched and I
like to get I've fallen orders of the
world I love all this other stuff
I love randomly want running down
corridors and shoot over MIDI so you
rather just walk on a large field you
say you know what we got to get up that
mountain sir that's gonna be a trial
that's gonna be a violation and we're
gonna take our rocks and our shoes and
our athletic apparel in this PlayStation
3 we're gonna take it up that mountain
I'm gonna tell you something right now
hope is one hell of a lawyer
this is
you changed my mind on it you know you
know what we we are and while people
might not like it but I love that
experience 100 we got a show so we got
we got a show hope some love of that
chat put put some put some more of those
into the bushes for death stranding goes
I need to feed on these into the bushes
with that strength the robe is not happy
with a lot of what do you say to the
people who say like um you know just a
lot of you know moving the packages
before the game like you have to go what
is your 20 hours in I feel like this
game never ends like this to me death
stranding is much closer in format to an
old game like a privateer or an elite
not only dangerous but these kinds of
old games where your primary focal point
is on slightly getting better and better
access to different ports in different
dangerous areas and building up your
ability to get to those areas and then
combine that with Hideo Kojima has
admitted wackiness where do we admit
makes it unapproachable for a lot of
people turns out it's my flavor problem
with other people saying whoa that got
real weird real fast but the actual
gameplay I think is not so unusual for
you know
yeah it's closer to maybe a Euro Truck
Simulator or D or something like that
any time you you anytime you visualize
and explain a game by saying is the Euro
Truck Simulator oh yeah we're gonna have
to get some more of those bushes in that
Chad ever have any problem with people
disagreeing with me in fact I love
passion one way or the other I really
hate ambivalence on those kind of things
so no problem listen I love the fact
that everybody has a different opinion
of the game and it's so diverse going
across the boards you know some people
say they play it they didn't get it some
people say they play and they got it
some people say they play it and they
hate it some people say they play it and
they love it you're wanted upstairs and
they love it because I love it or
something you need you know the best
thing that I've learned put this
training of what it really is done man
is it replaced nyquil for me sometimes
when I'm tired number years and I
haven't played des training before and
that's always nice no that's the thing
to when it comes to and listen remember
I was playing on charted like when it
comes when it comes to death stranding
it's actually the game play for me that
it is a total Zen just turn your brain
off and relax game yeah the sound design
as well to me is unmatched
like I've never there are blizzards in
this game where it actually sounds like
I'm in a blizzard like I'm in a snow
storm the environmental design is bar
none it's just it's a weird story that
we got stealth 40k backers what a mic
check is good I'm here the champion of
JRPGs my good friend stealth what he
can't always good to have you around man
first of all how are you doing and what
have you been playing man I'm doing good
it's been a long time I've been playing
a lot of Smash Brothers are you playing
that is exactly what is happening now
are you dealing with the
Arai a lot of people upset said it's too
much Fire Emblem character love or how
do you stand on now he's very curious
what they ask you that um ignore most of
it honestly but yeah I mean honestly in
a roster of 80 characters um I don't see
how you can complain about anything
really
it's if you guys do a pretty quick yeah
very easy to complain about stuff on
Twitter but I mean I mean was that my
first choice no but you know that's why
else you do it was it was up to you who
would you want to see that hasn't been
revealed
um I probably like to see somebody from
Kuwait ECMO maybe Ryu Hayabusa maybe
someone from the Disgaea series I don't
know if anyone here is familiar with
that but the bombs yes I don't see why
that wouldn't work I mean at this point
I think soccer I could make anybody
playable and fun and you know so I trust
him to do that and it's now be good
I'd love to see a Geralt I'm surprised I
haven't I think the biggest thing people
need to stop taking away from the fact
is the fact that you know you're gonna
get more smash characters I'm gonna use
in this next like six people and you're
complaining about the first one may I
hope just just cuz I don't really care
about the Nintendo stuff I hope there's
six Fire Emblem characters yeah I mean
people wanted King K rool he put that
character and people wanted Simon
Belmont he put he he's put in like
favorite characters and you know people
lose their mind over the one Fire Emblem
character he wants he's doing a better
job reading Japanese to that platform
King oh
if they're not careful it'll be all fire
maybe the heads of the three houses is
half of the next path I've have the next
back yes
I did anything upsetting that's the
survey good that still did we got a lot
of show so we gotta get going so uh
actually last week's poll results are in
and the people have spoken with the
rumors of the ps5 having a faster SSD
solution to the Xbox series X do you
think any more Hardware advantages will
eventually be revealed by Sony as we get
closer to the PlayStation 5 launch the
winner of the three way il people with a
fairly commanding 69% of the vote is no
the Xbox series X court Saudi off-guard
group coming in at second place at only
24 percent of the vote was yes Sony will
strike back with more features group and
exactly coming in at last place with
only six percent was the I don't care we
just want more Xbox esram and the Kinect
three point oh group those who voted I
want to get Lord King on this what do
you feel that do you agree with the
people the round Phills that the the
series X court Saudi off-guard
well we knew he was gonna catch them off
guard cuz dance move Ryan was on doing
his own dance on his own he's out here
doing his thing and the fact that
anybody believed it they're gonna come
with more features gotta be out of their
mind
but listen everybody's entitled to their
own opinion this is the fun part this is
the speculation part but what we can't
deny the pure of facts of the matter is
filled ominous Maximus Spencer was on
that stage and he caught you off your
beam with that wobble back yeah so we do
got a super cherub please III want your
Jabari I've noticed your in the chat I
want you to really listen to this as I
say oh gee Jabari
we have a $5 super chair from Aaron this
is gay toppers advertising Xbox series X
is the fastest most powerful card so how
you feel about the Jabari you might
might want to put some into the bushes
in there in the challenge of re-vote
listen stop messing my boy listen he
definitely has been jumped
in which Twitter streets he's been J I'm
gonna tell you right now the best part
about what's been going on is j-dub has
been sending you out here and I'm
telling you don't mess with J job G
throws a grenade and you sitting out
here laying on top of don't do it man
listen I hate to be slaughtering you in
these streets
o reading goals brother right now J
grounded game one $2 super super chair
from honestly it's been fun seeing every
Sony outlet being predictions
[Laughter]
fan of Kraken aka not gonna John sell
whatever I want to thank the Lord's for
keeping my sanity in this hectic day of
work I am a bookie for I don't know I'm
not trying been aligned and martyring
all Super Bowl props and wages in this
insane but thanks to you guys I'm
listening and keeping my cool and there
goes ok no no no I'm just making sure I
go tell us the people actually willing
to read this a we miss
okay so we gotta keep going
Oh Lord here go dizzy look at dizzy to
hate for Cognito to read hashtag Chiefs
Kingdom
Patrick mahomes for super bowl MVP
Kelsie over kiddo thank you for being
patient wow you know you know it's funny
I'm in New England fan and for the first
time in five years I can actually relax
and watch the Super Bowl without
freaking out I'm upset good I'm upset
that my man Tom Brady is now where he
rightfully belongs I didn't get to the
first topic reports have come out and
looks like it has surpassed the 50
million mark sales numbers like we don't
even have to talk about the zookie
because I got something refuting that
and with this number it will probably
most likely put it ahead of the Xbox one
currently seems like to switch including
the switch classic and the light as so
fifty two point forty eight million
units the switch has now officially
surpassed the Super Nintendo with 49
million and it's quite Drupal its
immediate predecessor do we you ever did
at 30 million now on the flip side
obviously the Xbox earning report and
it's on the path to outsell the
PlayStation 2 people don't like talking
about that PlayStation I'll say it right
right here right now I want to see the
switch to beat the ps2 switch on the
flip side obviously Microsoft Orion
reports have come out it looks like they
fell the gaming revenue fell 21% all
roll from second quarter now I said the
gaming revenue fell in terms both
hardware and content and services and
the hardware fell as sharply as 43
percent content and services declined by
11 percent so Microsoft did respond in a
way they said that they decreased
revenue they think it's off with the
decrease of volume in our console soul
and they also feel that they blame the
third party tidal offset and broken
apart by growth in subscriptions and
most assume that that third party title
is fortnight King I just got one
question for you man it's a very
important question you just tell me the
first thing that comes to your mind who
did that for you to the realm let's
start off with our Lord Hogan stealth
want to get them in first um as far as D
like I said the early reports the first
part of this I want to start off with a
switch which is can the switch keep this
momentum and in how how do we feel about
their news and then the second part of
the question will be how concerned are
we obviously with the Xbox side and the
game and revenue stuff so let's start
with holde first let's get it you know
where you feel about these switch
numbers in these Xbox numbers first of
all you know as a as a gaming fan I
think it's fantastic when Nintendo's
working yes right you know the Wii U
felt a little bad you know honestly I
love Nintendo I've enjoyed a lot of
their output and it was great to see the
switch really take off
I actually thought when that first
teaser came out a couple years back that
it seemed like exactly the right thing
if they supported it properly and
clearly they have and with the Refresh
with the light I think it got a big bump
I think certainly stealth will be better
able to talk about that than I did do
but I think it got a big bump when the
light came out and I think they've got a
good management strategy you know I that
Pro is there somewhere it's gonna come
out sometime that's what I'm really
looking forward to I would like just a
little bit more power behind my Witcher
on the switch there's a touch more power
but you know I think they've got a plan
and I think at the end of the day it's a
great thing for all gaming fans Xbox
Sony and Nintendo to have somebody going
and blazing their own Trail the switch
is not like those other boxes or it and
all honestly all three are kind of
pursuing different paths that
point but it's great to have something
like that and for me personally so I'm
older than a few folks on this this
stream I would I would be willing to get
bet for me personally the switch offers
the ability to have that flexibility
where yeah if I need to play the
equivalent to star to valley or fire
emblem or whatever because my girls are
in the room or I need to give the TV
back and take it off its plinth mm-hmm
you know we have a shrine to the switch
if I need to take that off I can do that
I can play I can still be engaged with
the family yes and I love my xbox I love
my PlayStation but in certain respects
playing Assassin's Creed a Red Dead
Redemption or other these mature rated
games isn't a functional possibility for
me and I love that Nintendo has had that
success and I love the switch I've been
playing as I said Fire Emblem earlier in
this stream I also bought evil land
which was on sale this week I've been
enjoying those and it's just a great
place to go for what I love when I was a
kid which is kind of unique RPGs
side-scrollers JRPGs those kinds of
things when maybe those particular
genres aren't as well supported in the
mainline under the TV consoles so we got
to catch up on these super we got a chat
oh no it's it's love here in your input
man we just got to catch up on these
real quick so we got a $2.00 supercar
from stitch go commercials on the Super
Bowl so I'm assuming Super Bowl has good
commercials yes we got we got two dollar
super chat from the grounded gamers HDR
on Fox at sea because I was done going
on him because he's streaming on the
admin you know normally he's against
dreaming we got another two dollars
super chair from the ground game or
nothing but love for the Lord's go
Niners
let me get LMNOP with the 10 hours which
at Nintendo can keep milking switch for
another year with custom systems but the
hardware is old now how far can it go
eventually 2020 games won't well on
switch currently it's funny you say the
element appeals stand tuned for my take
when it's my turn I'll definitely dress
I got something to talk about there but
I want to get to stealth man I mean
obviously this is this is your lane
that's why I definitely appreciate you
coming on the show I want to know like
how are you feeling about this like I
said the success of my of the switch and
then obviously the the opposite would be
with the numbers with you like what's
going on with the Xbox division yeah so
let's talk about the switch numbers for
a second so in in in the US and Japan in
2019 switch had a better year than ps4
Xbox one have ever had yes
so yeah so can the momentum keep going
yeah because if you look at the bundles
this year I mean Sony and Microsoft
basically gave away ps4 and Xbox ones
like the $1.99 deals in like three games
um
Nintendo with the switch did better than
either of the systems ever had and they
didn't price cut and they're basically
bundled one game there were no but to be
fair like you know I feel like the
reason they don't do that kind of
bundling stuff now whoa is because they
have the light and they can give it two
hundred dollar product so I don't feel
like they even need to price cut once
the numbers stay high there's no need
for you to bend in money place they
should kill it and they still be doing
by mean the point being like they
haven't done anything
and they've already broken records this
generation and you know the numbers keep
going they will catch ps4 um that at
over 100 million I mean I think that's
that that's pretty likely
um yeah I think which probably has to
three more years left I mean we're we're
only entering year three of the switch I
mean it's not even that Oh in terms of
hardware it's all but in terms of how
long it's been on the market it's not
old at all um and you know in terms of
ports and can that happen um you know
like some developers like EA will just
never support the switch no matter why'd
they piss me off
I don't yeah yeah I just feel like if
they put it like a Mass Effect trilogy
Orem or a Madden
could you imagine just what that would
do like bar where's having a hard time
as it is man don't put no more but work
on they players don't understand the
thought process to avoid the switch
games on switch games you want to switch
money which is do you need I don't need
no money Madden's its know you want
fireball switch I'm curious now what do
you think is is going on with their
thought processes for in continue points
your point about ports
especially when the next generation is
coming because a lot of people are
concerned that when the next-gen
consoles come out you know and this is
Ashley what a microsomes well like the
scalability dam will be that much harder
yeah so to finish with EA um you know
they had a an earnings call yesterday
and then they and I don't know who said
it but someone said you know they see
that the top 10 sales on the switch so
they're all Nintendo games so you know
they're a little there but on the flip
side you know you know they could put
older games on switch and and make money
with very little cost so is that an
excuse maybe um you know but it doesn't
stop a lot of other developers from you
know making good money on it um and in
terms of next generation yeah there
there will be some games that just won't
be brought to switch but on the flip
side you know I think that lists as
smaller than people think though like at
the end of the day most of these games
are going to run on the Xbox one and the
ps4 standard I feel like the majority of
these games are going to be scalable
down they might it might look like Legos
but I do think you can't get root is
most developers don't even know that
they can run
games on the switch like with um the the
outer worlds yes like like her virtuous
had to come to them and say you know we
can actually run this on the switch and
no clue and they're like sure go go you
know you can do it switch you think I'm
gonna buy the game on a second I gotta
go free on my phone I'm gonna smack some
is supposed to take care of me sir I'm
not even looking at this which you think
I'm gonna do muddy bugs no do they add
to game pastor the switch in three years
when they do that it may add they're
streaming i'm able to stream games and
good fidelity then imma be over there
i got the switch I'm just waiting for
switch nice games like the exclusives do
yeah you know what was really the proof
of concept for me on the switch one so
this last couple months
they released alien isolation and that
is the most impressive port to the
switch that I it is just ninety percent
as good-looking as the PlayStation 4
that I have played through and if they
can continue to do that I don't know I
don't know who did that port maybe panic
button that was actually in house I
think we gotta get to the crux of this
hope did you purchase that for dollar
game which which for dollar game the
alien isolation what on the game right
now on everybody else I do purchase that
game at full price let me talk to you
about my life alright I'm doing alright
on money I'm not doing so all right on
time oh it's all it's all a balance of
resource oh you wasted it on that game
he said I'm gonna take $60 forty would
never know I would never know but okay
regardless to what you said okay forty
dollars has worked as portable
portability for you this is what I'm
just trying I'm trying to get to the
mind well so I was I had to take out my
cartridge for
which or that I bought again to play on
the switch first you understand but I
ran through white orchard before a big
closing call while I was not in my home
office right
iíve played alien isolation now on the
couch with my kids watching my little
pony instead of having to play it on the
Xbox
look at that convinced oh so that's what
works for me and yes to some extent that
thirty bucks that isn't okay well from
40 to 30 but I believe it was quoted
that it was what four dollars or five
free on game game which I also have I
know you flush in cash what I'm trying
to figure out is I don't have these
super chats wrong you know what you will
stand trying to get into the mind of the
switch owner because this is what I've
seen like my mind has been shut off shut
the doors I love my xbox man I'm not
against you but I also love every time
you play something on the switch you
gotta lock that door launched the
deadbolt and you don't even want to look
in that room you know y'all are
misconstruing this whole thing what I'm
seeing here I don't know man there's a
little pocket watching going all right
no no listen
people are getting height for old games
yeah at full price and I this switch has
got y'all with this kool-aid this
kool-aid is amazing I don't know what
type of kool-aid it is but when Hulk
said I can do portability they got him
that's the crux or the whole thing
together if I if I can hump lawyer hold
here for a second oh honey defense I'm a
practicing bird law lawyer here sounds
good
when I say you know some games you want
to play on the Diablo Diablo they're
just like oh yeah I helped King
understand the the portability factor
why have these titles that he considers
money versions why is this so important
money high price we gotta call it the
blurry virtually to agree with him in
the money if money is an issue then you
can't beat free or you can't be very
cheap and you know that the that's
something else and you know but I do a
lot of this I I do a lot of traveling
you know I love being able to take my my
switch with me you know I actually gave
him the office sometimes you know we all
bring our switches together and make do
tournaments you know so just kind of
yeah I just want to get your your
personal opinion do you personally feel
like The Witcher 3 is worth the price is
up that's on the switch I mean probably
no but apply it on the switch I'm gonna
buy it
you can rate now oh wow you know what he
he at me at King we could talk about the
real numbers on a switch the 420 is 720p
is an impressive port go yeah go stop to
go cheese well if you put go chiefs no
one's reading that cut my battery we're
gonna have to Bri up to Cognito around
let me say one last thing on this right
so as I've said earlier in this stream
I'm a little older than Sevilla and one
of my favorite pieces of technology is
essentially having the magic be in your
hands and watching that go forward
throughout the decades and so I still
look at holding that video game in my
hands and playing it and thinking about
the Game Boy and the game gear links and
a telegraphic portable MAME let's go
home link so good intend oh he's got
this intangible wrap around your head it
is kind of crazy like I'm listening to
time I love my that's what's going on
Dale okie got Stockholm Syndrome
if you listening to it right okay
the handheld aspect of it is the
majority of the gameplay that is this is
what I'm hearing and for them to have
that game they don't care if it's in 420
they don't care this is 720 they don't
care if they don't have any flaws they
don't they don't care as long as they
can have they gaming on the go
and I think Nintendo has struck a chord
with these gamers right because the Wii
U they didn't understand what the Wii U
was to be honest what you didn't know
who was an add-on to the red band idea
what it was I mean but one aspect is the
portability the other aspect is the fact
that Nintendo was publishing like 20
exclusives a year on switch and that's
really the other thing is I mean they're
they're just killing it with the
exclusives he's just letting self talk
anytime he wants to talk so you could do
that class no it's just why don't you
hold up that phone card either because
we all know you'd be playing the X cloud
right now yeah we look we get caught up
in resume don't be too but right now the
power of the switch is the exclusives
right like that is what that's why I get
get to my switch that's why that's why
call gloves to switch it's the exclusive
say that I'm sweating bullets because
animal crossing is common sauce I'm
gonna try their kids they're bringing
out games they're publishing games
unlike I've seen Nintendo do in use
before first of all ghost it's not even
my blood what I'm trying to figure out
yeah what I'm trying to figure out was
winwaker why do they keep giving these
people
these games that I don't care about but
they won't give me the games I want
that's remade well they make you wait to
go to Lake anyway kind of like
Microsoft's making me wait for that
Japan support like I understand like
when people like lose their mind at
certain ports like yeah like when I see
The Witcher 3 port on my these guys it's
gonna tell you like every ports amazing
whatnot but they're opening their
bridging platform together right like
they are introducing a platform that's
never had the witcher so to a lot of
nintendo fans which is a brand new
experience innovation so a bit that's
that's what they're opening the other
bad king has a rebuttal he wants to talk
me and that the whole topic is so you'll
switch out selling and switch going
pushing forward right had this thing
starts falling flat on his face do these
ports come out no so what they're doing
is chasing the dollar right so we're
saying that going forward the fact that
the switch is selling so good they don't
care what type of ports they put out
there some of these ports are hitting in
some of these port authority but they're
making these ports and listen and listen
call a spade a spade is because they are
selling right you know when they weren't
selling when it was we you and it
weren't something was no sports it was
no support it was nothing but it's the
exclusives that boost the platform that
gets more eyes on the platform which
then gets those eyes to look at other
opportunity laughs in the room with the
the success of Indies I mean we've had
countless devs on I hope you come on and
say look the fact that they've had their
title on you know the switch and they've
done substantially better financially
with those ports so it's definitely in
behaving and I already say all jokes
aside ooh hear what you're saying yeah
you don't understand like the logic
behind it why would you pay for an
inferior version over the older product
but appeal yes oh so the switches are
portable outselling consoles should be
in the same league as eggs and Apia it
is in the same league here's the
question and I'm glad elemental peel
brothers transition with that first part
in the far is um now
we do know obviously is 2020 the Xbox
series acts the places you find are
coming right so the question I'm gonna
bring it back to your so our hope is
that you know do you think they can keep
this momentum at the release of those
consoles you know I'm saying do you or
do you think there's still niche enough
that they couldn't survive because the
power disparity is going to be greater
now hope so what do you think about that
when those system next gen consoles
arrive well I think someone else earlier
on the stream said the right thing here
which is that the Xbox strategy we're a
little bit unclear on the Sony strategy
because they've gone to ground for a
little bit now but that the Xbox
strategy is clearly that series X is
just going to be essentially a almost
kind of iterative jump over the series 1
X which was over the 1 because
everything's gonna be playable on all
those right and I think you can get some
good performance increases some
resolution increases some nice effects
on the X but if it has to be played on
the one chances are it can be played on
the switch not a Microsoft exclusive
I will also say that there's been rumors
now for forever that there is at least
iterations in Nintendo that they're
going to do an iterative jump the pro
whatever it wins I do wish all recently
which was shut down for 2020 true and I
think that if it is shut down for 2020
then the thought process would be we
don't want to launch against the series
acts in the mine we want to hold it a
little bit which I'm and if the X and
the 5 don't jump off the shelves and if
they don't necessarily have something
that is really a system seller or if
they just you know they're just done
with their honeymoon phase after 3-4
months and the switch pro in 2021 in
March would you be the 3-year
anniversary of the original I think
Sybilla is released then I think that a
switch can say okay now we are just 1/2
step back from the new platforms again
and we continue to kind of slot into
that spot where we have right now I just
got a question how many times that many
two times throughout the years are we
gonna have to keep shooting this switch
Pro down this is not happening all right
let's get out date stealth
what do you feel I mean hogs made a good
point you know Nintendo has been very
very tactical with their their lingo
even the time when you know people knew
a switch light was coming and at the
time I have nothing planned and then
later that you switch like you can't
when when when Nintendo says we have
nothing planned for 2020 that's just
them saying we might or we might not but
we're not gonna tell you here take that
that's really all that means and when
they announce something goes bad
communication well when they announce
something they're not gonna do it just
because an analyst or they were asked
the question during a you know an
earnings call they'll do it when they're
ready to do it you know they might not
have plans now but they might have plans
and may or whenever
so Nintendo kid can get away with you
asking something and if they say they're
doing it they're doing it if you say
they're not doing it they're still doing
it yeah basically
so yeah they actually have to be very
careful about what they say so
commitment is much worse than non
commitment from a legal perspective Oh
cake level to get our stuff for what
question no but what don't you think I
mean obviously the rumors were very hot
and heavy a fork a switch and all the
sudden like what do you think
realistically you can expect from a pro
version of a switch um probably better
performance games that weren't running
at 60 frames per second might um I kind
of see it the way that the new 3ds was
where they brought Xenoblade to it and
you know it just I don't think there's I
think there's gonna be any exclusive
games to it but I think games will run
better right um I think they might look
slightly better
um the system might be faster with
loading um and I think it there might be
some of those um things but you know in
terms of like the new systems like
they're probably gonna launch more
expensive than you know even the switch
is now at 299 I mean I think so that the
Nintendo switch is going to get a pro
version but it's not going to work with
the switch I think it's gonna be there
next gen no I'm not talking about in
2021 I'm talking about
the next switch that comes out is going
to do with their next-gen switch I guess
I don't see them doing that that
alienates they're the already massive
audience that listen like I did with the
we like they did we you was a failure
the way you could play we you could play
Wii games I'm thinking that this is a
jump in this case that what why should
PlayStation abandoned the ps4 it's such
a it says they're not going them out of
it eventually they're going was in place
that I feel can be played but though I
remember that the ps2 had a hat support
from launch into like 2013 so let's get
that out of the way right ok so they're
gonna be is there gonna be PlayStation 5
exclusives no yes so why I think games
on the ps4 if it was so successful
because what what's gonna probably
happen with the jump from ps4 to PS 5 is
what they've said is they don't want to
alienate what is a huge marketplace for
so they make exclusive games for the
next three years he's different from
three years when we talk about
alienating or isolating one of the
things you have to take into account is
brand management right just goodwill
towards the brand you go and you have
the most successful console sales in
2019 and then three years after launch
in 2016 you say screw you here's
switch-kun good luck that's not great
for an Intel about 20-23 that's gonna be
a new switch it's gonna be the new
switch just like it's gonna be it's
gonna be backwards compatible and it's
going to go forwards compatible to one
of these is gonna be called super
switcher I'm gonna be very upset one
thing it has to play carts of every
single switch because III think Nintendo
is done with the traditional console
game you think that anybody on this
panel understands exactly how Nintendo
thinks or why they do what they do
so what I don't really this out I
honestly believe Nintendo will move at
the beat of their own drum and anytime
that they want their own dramas handheld
yeah but listen listen because they can
control you I've seen alright so the
fact that they can control you listen
they put that thing on VR which was a
lab oh just real quick this phantom
cracker
we got a five dollar super check for
final cracking first time I hear power
will power and switch and it sittings
together but if you guys like mud go
chat with a smiley face a little
continued katikut did the fact that it
matters right I know a switch pros gonna
come I know everything is gonna be back
up at now in in a normal we're up world
this stuff makes I just don't I know
this is a normal world tell me at what
point in time has this switch followed
anything that is normal so what makes
you think they're gonna make a pro you
know why I say they're gonna make a pro
in my head it makes sense I want them to
make sense at some point in time I want
them to make sense right but they have
not at all so do I have faith that
they're gonna make a pro hell no what do
I think they're gonna make a pro sense
what if we put percentages go around the
realm what's your percentages of a pro
hundred hundred I'm saying dirty I'm a
Sam I'm gonna say yeah I'm a goal with
the 35 because I don't trust these dude
has not done one thing that makes me
think they care about power in any shape
where they know nothing if we can have a
kid with a cardboard box on his back and
they said they say yo we're bringing the
stuff that you find irrelevant this
stuff
yes sir to have us playing with
cardboard I think the thing that airs
about is they care about their Indies
they've been very supportive in that
thing because they know that their
portable aspect to their console always
sells Indies there's a reason that all
of everyone is looking at the the
Nintendo switch to play indie games
including myself they care about their
their first party titles because that's
what really brings in the money
obviously if you look at that list
almost everything's outsold every
PlayStation and an Xbox exclusive on
there and then they're like if you want
a game on our platform in your third
party you're welcome to do it I mean we
got we got something I mean you could
try to this is fun
unless antenna does beat a drum but like
I said this Lane I think they find they
just never try to combine them yeah yeah
the day of something where they can do
switch to three yeah or you know they
didn't necessarily have that before I
agree I think again the perfect for
villain I'm a vita guy and the key the
problem I have the Vita again the lack
of the dual analog right the fact that
the analog wasn't a button then you have
to do sets of shifts so this replicates
full functionality like a next-gen
controller and you can play all games
with that part of it I think they're
fine with four factors I mean stuff on
this rail for it yeah my question to you
selfies being that they already have
this part with the stick when when they
took the switch and made it a standstill
right okay that was a very bold move
because what you did was you started
people believing in one area of the
switch that it was a versatile machine
mm-hmm but then you took away all
versatility and you made it a but this
is a master of the three yes hold on one
second you made it into the success of
the 3ds
now get this part right let's say they
use that successor to the radius as they
handheld joint right
and they really out called me home do
you think they're gonna make a
traditional home console while still
keeping the switch brand and a switch
label because the switch officially took
over for the 3ds yeah so do you think
they can officially make a home console
to equal I get close enough to the power
to PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X to
compete in that area while still having
their hand hold my handheld market
intact so so one of the things that
Nintendo said when the switch was coming
out about 3ds 3ds was like $75 at the
time and they were like yeah we really
need something that's super cheap and so
the switch light was in direct response
to the fact that they didn't have
anything cheap disruptive with Pokemon
mom to sell with parents so they really
needed something at that cheap price
point couldn't Nintendo theoretically
build a monster um you know in terms of
yeah they could because they did it with
Gamecube it was more powerful than ps2
mmm-hmm and they still didn't get nearly
the sport that ps2 did um you know so
could they do it yes um I see them
really liking the switch like what it
does being able to play it on a TV and a
handheld I think they really are in love
with that model and I think really the
light only exists because they needed
something cheaper to bundle with Pokemon
holidays I think you know I want no
issue with the like idea of the day they
do call it the switch light so you know
it's a little light on the switch
features into a point it's people like
myself I don't even know where my dock
is right you know I don't care about the
console aspect the switch is a handheld
to me but we can't deny that my car my
crescendo they do promote really slip
that Nintendo does promote this as a
console right yeah I mean yeah if you
like watches like the Japanese
commercials like
most of like the first part of the
commercial starts with like a family on
the TV and then you know they're they're
traveling somewhere on the train or
something so they note that dual aspect
of this town t-to it at the basketball
court don't forget ya whether they
stopped playing actual basketball I mean
yeah they're little idealize in the way
they market it I mean I know there was
one I think I posted this where I was
watching one of their commercials and
like there was one scene where they were
like in bed with the lights off and
nobody arrived and that's like the most
realistic you know commercial for them
was when the baby was crying and they
got in the car then the baby was only
quiet inside the car and they drove
around the block and the two parents
were sitting inside the car playing
swish I said I said first of all I used
to do that with my daughter and if I had
a switch I've been better yo has L never
expected this little again in psycho
game well let's go down brother find out
a super chat Nintendo has effectively
taken themselves out of the home console
market and sticking to what they do best
hashtag handheld let's get stuff and I
want to get our bad bit to finish up
yeah I mean if people think that the pro
is gonna be an Xbox Series X or a PS 5
it's not well it's gonna be is a switch
that runs the games better um faster
like that I mean I mean but in I mean in
like three to four years Nintendo will
come out with the next switch and it'll
probably be called switch 2 or something
or new or but that will happen but it's
not gonna happen it's put a you areand
everybody that infused it's not gonna
happen at three-year mark it's just not
going to in Tendo is selling way too
much sauce I mean in Tendo sold more
software last year then PlayStation and
Microsoft have ever dreamed about
selling from party why looks like is
rolling the money right now and then
they're not gonna like cut that off URLs
for a long
you know this guy y'all gotta stop
feeding this guy yeah to be real it to
me it's all about price point it's not
about power
that's what the switch is proven over
the years is that if you could get the
masses on to this idea onto this gimmick
whatever you want to call it then
they'll adopt it if they could see it
believe it hold it play it they'll get
on it when it comes to switch Pro I
always say just stop calling it switch
Pro it's gonna be a switch to point out
it is going to be a more powerful more
capable switch it's not gonna play 4k
it's not the way it doesn't need to what
Nintendo needs to probably start
worrying about is X cloud is stadium
when those when streaming starts to
match the fidelity that you're going to
get and the quality you're going to get
on Nintendo's switch so you can expect
in the future
Nintendo attempt us to start to
future-proof with better tack but it's
going to be more stable and you have to
also think about battery life and
battery technology as well moving
forward so ya know 4k but I'm thinking
yeah something 1080p oh yeah they gotta
focus on 1080p because they can let's
nail down this 800 K and then after we
get the chain ATP masters my friends on
the service to let's go there oh my gosh
Chris you see there with tendons are
batches of the brain was look I'll
finish you up the time and we move on to
the Xbox portion which is okay look I I
hate what you guys say I think I'm
leaning to what what what hold is saying
in a sense that I'm actually glad that
it's not supposed Pro is not coming out
this year because I would prefer it come
out after the series makes it please if
I saw at least
you know again are they gonna close the
gap probably not but to what stout is
saying you know as long as they can get
you know 60 frames per second I still
don't really care about the resolution
my main thing is that what bad--but said
is key
most people with money or not having
switcher having 2k having MORTAL KOMBAT
having those things on a platform for a
group that normally wouldn't get that
they're going to play yeah oh there we
go
you said something that really makes no
sense it's like a car saying I don't
care that we can't fly a bikini driver
there's more Toyota Camrys in you goes
bro this is right you're right but
that's not a spec I'm talking about you
see when you say that you know we don't
care about the results you have no
choice you don't have a choice it's not
like they brought a pole to you did you
want 720 g1 1080p so there's no choice
understand Hogue has helped me like he
literally helped me understand he put it
in the terms because hoga scash flush
right so it being cashflow she said it's
not about the cash King it's not about
that so that you sort of cash came it's
it's really about the portability he
said when my daughter's is watching my
little pony
oh wait mop my muddy switch it I feel
him when he says this when he says he's
playing alien isolation because IP won a
huge case and he even got this money
yeah he just sat back to the side and he
pulled out his alien isolation and
looked at the judges you know what it is
something and I'm down with hope this is
what it is I found out he's doing it
because he can you're doing it because
you can we can't yeah we have
we try to take our PlayStation outside
we're gonna burn in the Sun no we can't
leave the comfort of our home without a
Playstation we can't leave it where our
Xbox well now we can do with X clouds um
but right now the switch is women
because they could do it baby
and I feel was gay at a good
I don't think X clothing that's gonna
hurt switch too much I think you're
gonna have some people that will play on
the X cloud that is an extension of
their Xbox X I don't got Pokemon expert
cloud dog got animal crossing X cloud
dog got the games that actually sell
switches mmm that's a good point
let me put these super chance real quick
um Johan said we'll just land your final
switch at Nintendo are a bunch of cheap
people they recycle old technology give
it a spit shine and sell it to you for
300 here let's go I mean can't really
we're getting sold cardboard this is the
PC master baristas the Lambo of gaming
consoles or the over that bed is brand
new he stuck their PC master-race maybe
it's that well you know if you spend
$5,000 on your PC - you gotta come
outside and cap sorry sir I don't
subscribe to your philosophy I only paid
500 for my ex and it's still
whitewashing yo PC master-race I want to
get to the second part of the tower
Giovanni which again is the Xbox
division obviously like I said the
numbers came out you know I'm saying
it's sit down in gaming you know people
some people some people go ahead and get
that super chat because it's a switch
super treble of streaming takes off
considerably the switch will not sell
beyond 150 million to streaming
targeting I don't think how the old 3
billion size market you see those on
business plans a little bit yeah in
terms of like the Xbox numbers um they
don't give us like actual hardware
numbers when they say it
like 43% down we don't know what that
means anymore right um so like I don't
really stress out about that because you
know 43% down I mean we don't know
exactly how much hardware they're
selling cuz they're not telling us
anymore they don't tell us what software
is selling either right so you know when
people immediately see down I mean if
that eclis if they were selling super
high and they were 20% down but they're
still selling more than the other
systems it doesn't matter if you're if
you down which I don't think it's the
case here right but um you know it's
just hard to know but yeah we're not
getting any specifics but my question
you said the only thing I'll be honest
the only thing I was concerned about was
yeah the content and services aspect
because you know hardware to me that
makes sense you're at the end of a
console generation right people are not
looking and then let's be honest
Microsoft has notoriously at least the
last two consoles have already
foreshadowed and predicted a next
console to their base right so I could
see the Microsoft base say on people who
may be interested in an Xbox platform
saying hey you're gonna mate why why
would I get an Xbox one X right now
you've just announced a Scarlett I'll
wait
so I get that part but the part that
little surprised me was content and
services especially with the push for
game pass and it appears game pass is
doing successful for them they they
could constantly promoting the service
to expanding the features and so on and
so forth they're talking about it on X
cloudy talking about
so I guess again no we don't have
specifics but does that part even
surprise you a little bit what content
services in this suppose it is only down
five percent though yeah right 1111 it's
not down crazy but also that there's not
like a mega hard blue yeah there's not
like a mega exclusive for her
information pass or or some of their
services so it's like it's not gonna go
up forever right now let's talk about
the beanie baby situation fortnight
fortnight is a unique property mm-hmm it
was at its peak or peak level one right
last year that's what they at least
everybody has implied that they are
addressing when they say we're having
issues with a third party that's the
difference between year-on-year in
quarter
order and so if you were to take that
out if there was some algorithm or some
metric you could use to at least flatten
it into something normal that fortnight
wasn't explosive and 11 probably isn't
11 it's probably 2 or 3 or 5 and that
starts to look a lot more like the
seventh year of a console run and so
that isn't that unusual in my opinion
and and what I really loved about this
night you heard me talk about when we
were talking about Nintendo yes is Sony
is pursuing the the version of the game
console that we had know and love
stronger more powerful still sits under
your box and it's going to be that and
Nintendo has done this weird hybrid
thing that I love some people don't on
this very stream and they're doing that
over here wrote Xbox has said all right
we the Xbox one TV TV TV it didn't work
out we tried to then be essentially baby
PlayStation for the bulk of this
generation and then we leaped it with
the X and that's not really where we
want to live what do we want to do we're
Microsoft but one of the biggest
companies in the world
we love recurring revenue we love
software as a service we love the
constancy of our budgets and what this
affords us in the digital age and so
we're gonna focus our energy on game
pass on recurring revenue on this very
new subscription model of video gaming
and it's and it's different from what
Sony's doing they're going to be
competing in a similar space for the
console under the TV but Microsoft
ultimately isn't only in bed with that
model so if they come in millions less
than the PlayStation that isn't a that
isn't a failure point that isn't a
success point that we can easily
determine just against what Sony's going
to put out there in their press releases
so yeah it makes things like on this
stream and these conversations and the
iron Lords more difficult to have
because those numbers are essentially
going to be calculating different things
as they move further and further apart
but I personally as a business guy as a
law guy as a video gamer who loves this
industry and this hobby I think this is
fascinating we are in the middle of an
experimental prototype yes
genre of where this industry can go and
you've got three different models that
you can follow right and ultimately in
my opinion I'm an optimist I know you
hear that a lot about lawyers lawyers
are all optimist
they're all very happy people but I'm an
optimist and I think all three can
succeed targeting different things
targeting different people and different
user bases and I'm very excited to see
what three years down from this launch
looks like for everybody this is
exciting let me let me jump in hold on
work it's moving to file a super chat
content and services is DLC and digital
purchases Xbox game pass subs and I'm a
you don't know what that it may you
increase what I might not know what Mau
increase but anyway thanks kids move I
appreciate that element appeal for the
$4.99 super check Xbox is down well
guess what Sony is down to everyone is
down except Nintendo and we have our
tempest Sun for the fight out of super
check get into the topic late but what
about Nintendo looking Animal Crossing
for console no matter how many profiles
you have cheap that's a stealth question
treiber's that's a controversial about
which girl is here as well but look all
monthly active news Thank You Delilah I
appreciate that home look I mean Hogue
is bringing up some fantastic points in
reference to philosophy and I think that
a lot of I don't want to see it
antiquated thinking cuz people get mad
when I say that but um I want to say a
lot of picture what is it a traditional
tradition that's a better word thank you
thank you so most people are locked in
to how the console generations always
used to go right so what Microsoft seems
to be doing seems foreign a lot of
people say hey how can they sustain
themselves with this new strategy about
ecosystem like this seems to be about an
ecosystem getting you in bed with game
passing all this other stuff and then I
guess I'm glad you said what you said as
far as on the whole services down me
because I've been seeing you know
people's response to debt services being
down like you see that game pass stuff
ain't gonna work that's what they're
saying oh they like this is a reflection
you know okay I'll get it bad but I know
you but the other so know what you guys
did respond attack a lot of people are
saying see you guys were drinking the
game pass juice and the services are
dead
what you gonna say right and that's the
thing like I'm a PlayStation guy right
lovely I even bought the fantastic I
look at the hardware sales I I look at
the hardware sales numbers not not
shocking not surprising you know we all
over again seven years this generation
so that's not surprising
the service is sure that's that's a
little weird but I also see that as
possibly people going from you know
migrating from Xbox Live over to game
pass but we also see the huge success of
game passing I want to quote Benji sales
yes where he says game pass subs doubled
this quarter yes I rocket and guess the
problem is software sales are down a lot
which is bundled with services reported
right thank ya the problem cake is ready
the problem is that Microsoft is so V
when they're reporting these numbers and
what these numbers actually mean what's
bundled with these numbers but on the
other hand as well is that game pass
this isn't this isn't a game pass is not
working this is something straight up
telling you it's W doubled game pass is
succeeding it's getting in the my chair
I'm a PlayStation gamer I'm subscribed
to ultimate for the next two years
I love ultimate I think it's a fantastic
service hundred percent oh yeah when I
when I take a look at these numbers
nobody should be worrying and nobody
should be waving a flag of who's winning
who's that stupid at the end of the day
we're all gamers and at the end of the
day as well police station in a few days
they're gonna probably come out with
their report and it's gonna probably
look just as bad yeah yeah I mean if you
look at like the ps2 years let's say um
Sony was number one in the United States
in Europe in Japan they're number one
everywhere um a Nintendo had the Game
Boy Advance sold like eighty million
units but was never number one so
Nintendo was like okay how can we
compete and had a system more powerful
than the PlayStation 2 in the Gamecube
um and they were like how can we can how
can we possibly be number one and they
did something radically different with
the switch
yes and they were again um if you look
at now Nintendo has a stranglehold on
Japan and right now they have a
stranglehold in the US and they normally
compete with Playstation in the US right
and and as a strangle so Microsoft like
okay how can we be number one at
something mom how could we compete do
something different
um you know and that's and that's and
that's you know gets a pass they're
doing right um that's something that
really that they're number one in and
they can be um you know they also get to
create the narrative yeah they do have
this thing matters the chat is attacking
the chat say when you guys are saying
game pass you know as double they're
saying because of the fact that I can
see the color but you can so we had a $5
well I think that's pounds I don't know
anyway does the power this is a panel
know the number of handheld sold in
Japan and China over the last three
years
I mean switches sold 10 over 10 million
regular switches of Japan and the switch
light is over a million and that's been
out for half a year and I don't even
know yeah yeah so yeah and yes which has
done better in Japan this year then and
then the first three then you know any
year that that's been out so but yeah I
mean it but but but the three
yes has sells like 66 hundred units a
week it's done okay so check this out
guys right listen listen no no listen
okay what you guys don't understand
about business the fiscal year ended
this is where you had your black Fridays
and stuff like this is why you get those
sales to get rid of old stock right so
with Nintendo Microsoft and Sony was
doing was getting rid of all stock what
Nintendo didn't do was they didn't drop
a price so then Humber's is always gonna
look higher right they sold at a higher
pace what Microsoft and Sony did was
they lowered the price of the existing
hardware so you're selling a higher
volume at a lower rate at a lower price
point right and they also find up three
games where they use bundling you
throwing your stuff away you're giving
me out of the your hands because what
you wanted to do is sell out of your
constant your um your stock right
because going into the future you don't
want to have a whole bunch of old
PlayStation fives and I'm your
PlayStation 4 and Xbox X's going in you
want to make room for the new Oh kids
smooth put in this way Xbox made 11
billion in 2018 and 10 billion in 2019
nobody's getting fired for only making
10 billion dollars put it in color for
you then all right here you go crystal
bar for the $2 Super chat is anyone
playing game pass on switch okay is
anybody playing game pass on Sony no um
the thing is when you're looking at
services being down just like you were
saying game sales is tied to services so
if you're getting 200 games in game pass
this is why game passes up and services
is down if you're giving to 200 games in
game pass why the hell are you buying
games it literally makes zero sense for
you to go out and actively purchase
games lesson star well
his games that's not going to be able to
come to the system what people have been
being getting done to them is they're
being burnt I've been burnt before right
pause um you've purchased a game and
then lo and behold a month or so later
it comes out in game pass how annoying
is that and then you probably didn't get
a chance to play the game that you
purchased a month before and then when
you get a chance to play it it's in-game
pass so then you save yourself it makes
you skittish when you go to the store to
purchase because the first thing on your
mind if your Xbox own is hmm do I really
need to buy this one modified right now
is it going to be in-game pass you by I
don't want to real quick before we move
on I want to shout out to the 187 people
in the chat definitely I like but you
guys don't mind I'd like to get it to a
hundred before the podcast it's only
like og open on that point I know you
had a sub to say real quick wait I'll
give it back oh yeah no first of all I
already have hit like so I always just
like to hear the sound of my own voice
um but what I will say is a couple
things first of all I'm in total
agreement on game pass so game pass I
think is a success I think it will be a
success for Microsoft but I think like
most things when you're trying novel
business approaches there's no guarantee
there's a lot of rocky shoals to still
be navigated here one of them was just
identified with how people are going to
respond to the notion that this thing
could be free in a little while there
was a game that came out middle or
towards the end of last year called
remnant and bashes end-of-days fallen
ashes can't remember the entire title
remnant I was told very good things
about it by my game developer brother he
said you should get it I looked at it so
it was a double a game said this feels
to me like this is going to be a game
pad I said this feels like a game pass
game I'm sure
and sure enough I think two months later
a month ago or so comes out on game Pass
and I say Yahtzee
we did it but Microsoft yeah I won but
they have to navigate that third-party
relationship exactly how those people
are getting compensated that made those
games whether they're satisfied with
getting the money for that they're going
to get from games
past participation over what they could
sell through and having all those
conversations he is what all those
lawyers all those business people all
those vice presidents with the titles
that we can't remember at Microsoft are
going to be focused on because this is
gonna be their focus for revenue
generation it's no guarantee I have
confidence that they'll figure it all
out but there's a lot of places for this
to go run whenever you're dealing with a
third party that's essentially creating
your content you think it's we talk our
lategame pass right but there's an
analog to that and that's movie pass now
they had all sorts of trouble with fraud
and things with we can talk about it on
a different stream but that particular
service had to rely on third party
content providers third party premises
providers in respect to the theaters and
whenever you have those multifaceted
kind of relationships you've got
potential for problems and we'll hope
this is where I say game paths
circumvents your theory right okay
because every last one of Microsoft
first party games are inside game past
day and gate they purchased 15 new
studios to ensure constant at a steady
content at a steady stream so this is
where the theory of them relying on
third-party software no it is not a
crutch it is the asset actually because
while you wait for their every three
months a new Microsoft game to come out
every three to four months for the year
for it to come out like a new Marvel
movie you have the little movies in
between that you can hold off until the
next big game release and I think that's
where the change is that's where
Microsoft has changed the game actually
because you know Sony is hell-bent on
not trying to put their stuff in
PlayStation now day and date now I don't
know Jim dance move Ryan if I could say
one thing just early first off Jim Ryan
knows the polka he's good if you go off
Kings statement here that's it that's a
huge thing when games are tied in with
services and you have a game like use of
war five come out phenomenal and it
rivals fortnight for a few weeks most of
those people
didn't buy that game at 60 bucks he
bought it for the dollar five bucks
whatever the promotions going on right
now
and that's what a lot of people are
they're not looking into the weeds on
this they're looking you know they're
looking from binoculars you know twenty
yards away it happened to y'all right so
when it comes to game pass in the future
of it King I think you nailed it
100% right they have 15 Studios those
Studios have multiple teams we see it
out of Ninja Theory right they got in
there working out three games once
coming out next month and the other two
look insane that's what Microsoft's
known for their going forward hey we are
we're gonna have this one main game
hell-blade then we're gonna have this
test game which is gonna be a weird and
horror game you're seeing that with a
city and right now you know they're
working on outer world sue but at the
same exact time they got this weird
Honey I Shrunk the kids thing going on
but they're they're trying to balance
out this portfolio of theirs and growing
after Satan so so here what I would say
on this is that at least up until now
and we can give him the benefit of the
doubt for their new look with all their
new studios and everything else I don't
think anybody would say that Microsoft
first party is outputting like Sony or
Nintendo mm-hm and so when you've got
the game pass out there and you've got
essentially what should be the
foundational pillars of your service as
every quarter it's gonna be a big
Microsoft game that is still something
that has to be proven in terms of value
in my opinion and what I'm saying is in
the ancillary if it doesn't rise to that
Nintendo or Sony value it's still good
I like a lot of Xbox games don't get me
wrong 100% if it doesn't get to that
value they have to be very careful to
not a strange all of the third party
that is kind of adding in the mortar to
their bricks right well as that is more
that I constantly hear all the time from
my xbox friends is I want this game but
I think this is a good game pass game a
good way it was like game pass and
that's that's something that they are
gonna have to navigate in the future and
that might affect a few games I mean we
saw with control you know I saw when
when it was rumored in November
that has to hurt them in a way of light
whoa [ __ ] it's not coming just real
quick
what I've noticed is they real slick I
quote onto Microsoft real hustle okay a
lot of these games come into game past
and they have DLC they have all these
little purchase items that you can
purchase for these games it's inside
game paths I've noticed that with the
devil may cry and other games right and
you can purchase you can actually use
your DLC by DLC by in-game currency
whatever this is where the game gets
second life so when the game stops
living like Tekken 7 yes and I went
minute I got Tekken 7 for free but I had
to go buy all the DLC to get all these
characters they make money hand over
fist now I'm left with all this DLC that
I purchased that I didn't have to
purchase the game but when the game
starts to Lee about a game pass guess
who has to buy that game and all it's a
validate all that DLC that I still have
on my hard drive but I won't be able to
access it because the game is not
purchased so I must therefore buy the
game so sales of games is going to go up
once you get hooked on a DLC so they
give you giving it to you for free to
try right and technically whatever
you're paying monthly they give it free
to try but then once you try you say you
know what I want that extra content you
purchase that extra content now you get
an alert at the bottom the game that you
purchase that extra content is leaving
you get an extra 10% off when you buy
because you're part of game past and you
don't got the game you replayed it so
you know what this is the best time as
ever because it's getting really and I'm
a ready in right yeah so that didn't get
sold to you so I think he pass also
should be raising the profile of game
sales on dead game what we've seen is
yeah you know that a lot of these titles
are outside of the sales window right so
sometimes they jump in game paths and it
breeds that second breath of life into
it right on a revenue standpoint when
normally the cycle should have been
over already right the game has long
been released all the DLCs or whatever
is out but now it comes in a game pass
and then you see people say oh you know
what let me give it a give it a shot and
then like you said kidding okay maybe
anybody DLC or what have you but I just
theory has a point
but it describes why PlayStation now is
a failure Xbox following the Netflix
model smarter way to do it all right
shall I wrap with the fallacy of a chat
agree with what Hogue said earlier big
three will have different approaches but
can be successful in their own lanes
given how big and diverse the pie is
then we have names like that someone
else's job
why wouldn't Microsoft bid for the NFL
and NBA licenses to compete with Madden
and 2k create a first party sports
studio those would be system silly I
remember yeah I actually spoke to Phil
personally about this question a few
years back now as far as the license the
MLB license is what I spoke to
specifically looks like they don't have
to worry about that now with the whole
situation with MLB the show so that's
gonna be coming over and as far as dr
NFL and NBA license I believe the NFL is
exclusive whole - yep I believe yeah all
contracts end but yeah yes oh no I don't
represent electronic term we got a $2 2%
from restore Haiti's king is right
random spoons lies okay so let's get it
to that um I was gonna say I get stealth
right it's not that even get you on this
one as far as the old the whole revenue
thing and you know service yeah I mean I
think Microsoft is gonna be fine um I do
think that you know they they bought
those 16 Studios then we're hurting
see how that lands because what made me
a little nervous was Gears of War 5 was
supposed to be a pretty huge game last
year group and within like two weeks
everyone forgot it existed um the
conversation stopped yeah
I still play I still love it but that is
that is something what if they won't
give us numbers though so it's like well
you know how you can get numbers right
become a shareholder so so this is
because I've been going at J bar I've
been going at everybody so I got to keep
the same energy even though you are
panelists today I got to tell you if you
know pocket watching is the thing we
play video games we don't play numbers
this is what we're gonna do okay in
order to get that spreadsheet and hold
can attest to this in order to actually
have hard concrete numbers buy stock and
then we can know exactly what Microsoft
is moving and how they pushing in these
streets but the fact that certain stock
is not being purchased people is left to
speculate and knows people that are
speculating knows a pocket watches those
are individuals that have no intent on
buying stock or physically trying to
figure out what Microsoft is actually
doing because at the end of the day if
Microsoft goes under I've watched NEC
I've watched Sega I've watched data east
I have watched Hudson soft I have
watched numerous companies and
developers go under you know what this
guy kept doing yeah I kept on pushing
buying the next console the next company
whoever falls down I'm getting the next
duder steps up so have stadia has stadia
one and Microsoft fella guess who's
playing stadium this guy no but this is
the truth is this what we're talking
about stadia to the stock over box hero
can we say styling like corporate slave
oh well maybe it is corporate slave talk
a few pocket watching you want numbers
you want numbers go buy stock about
those numbers that much go buy some
stock go buy stocks do you really want
to know what Microsoft earnings is go
buy them stocks if you really are so
upset that Microsoft is not giving you
the numbers that you're looking for Oh
buying stock
watch without buying them
mr. J don't get those stocks baby then
you could tell me then you can come back
and tell me what's going on okay
could you concern I want you to ease
your concerns I want you to go bottle
stocks and Soldado we got some coming at
you net
hi Lord addict deep this color for this
one to particular roller
y'all got Nintendo stock of yahwah's got
Nintendo stocks was talking a lot
numbers earlier but members that Dave
revealed is remember they tried they'll
revealed with this yeah so I got I got
like bad news on most of this video
stream so so yeah the corporation's
absolutely owe their stockholders
certain financial reports certain
availability capitalization tables
things about nature there's a broad
swath of generally accepted accounting
practices that allow consolidation and
things that are not going to give you
the numbers that you necessarily want at
least not until you're willing to sue
them as a stockholder I can't honestly
recommend they have some they have some
good lawyers on their side they have a
lot of them which is probably more
important than how good they are you can
have a percent by the stocks you can say
I need to know exactly how many users
and how many sales you had of Gears of
War five you can go you could say do you
take it to the Microsoft vice-president
they'll say thank you sir know if you
have your annual report just like the
rest of our stockholders and then you
can say we're gonna sue under Delaware
law and they say come at us bro we got a
whole roomful people that do nothing but
sink courtroom let's go this is
hilarious now it look yes you know I was
surprised that the services wasn't
revealed you know as far as you know the
hardware it's like my Babbitt said it's
to be expected in a generation you know
I'm saying I knew you know kind of thing
I think to me what we should be
concerned out is if next earnings report
when you have a series X out you know
I'm saying in the wild and you have X
cloud released and
and gamepad supposedly flushing away
should flourish if those numbers still
replicate the same thing that we're
seeing now then it's filled ominous man
you gotta have a talk what's going on
but for right now no you don't say I'm
not concerned that in the least right
now you know it's something I figured to
be expected at the end of a console
generation that's what I got we got to
move on
got one more actually what topic to get
through with King has been chomping at
the bit for and yeah King what is going
on here and a lot of things about remote
play and the flexibility of remote play
what mummy and Jim dance moves Ryan has
put out they put out a little
questionnaire to individuals trying to
fill out you know what's going on would
you like to have a game pass
type of service on a Nintendo switch you
know plenty of Sony stuff on it and also
and also they want to know if you want
to be able to hook a controller
up to your phone a playstation
controller up to your phone to play
something and Jim dance moves Ryan has
always been in pocket Easy's
capitulating with your xbox where the
field offices move it no he's in
compliance is your exactly he's in
compliance Wow King I just saw a rupture
for two seconds people are at order hash
I could go buy those stocks is his
dominance spencer's of influence
influencing his PlayStation in an X
cloud type of way to get into services
like a big brother
all right let's give some context before
I give it to the baby
all right so apparently you know with
remote play there was research survey
survey that came out and actually it was
on reddit a guy posted screenshots
exactly of what this Sony remote
and serving was and some of the
questions were wait you as a PlayStation
owner like to play your role play on the
Nintendo switch Apple TV Android TV as
well as have functionality with the Xbox
controller and so on
so this definitely raised the eyebrows
you know of a few in reference to Sony
stance as far as you know I'm gonna say
playing with others use that terminology
right so this has a little bit of the
Internet in a tizzy because you know
when Microsoft announced you know things
like this with um X cloud and game past
and you know any device knows what the
terminology is used and a lot of people
felt you know by Microsoft doing that
they're devaluing you know the brand and
so forth so a lot of the Xbox contingent
we're hearing that kind of rhetoric so
wanna bring this to the roundtable with
this information coming out and it seems
to be legitimate I've seen two other
sources you know state that they've
gotten these surveys with the Nintendo
switch and the Xbox mentioned do you
think this D values what they're trying
to do a remote play or do you think this
is just a new direction with Jim Ryan
and where he's going so I want to get
bad bit first because he's my
PlayStation guy and then I want to get
stealth in the order and in holes so
I've made a video about this on bad bit
games you can check it out and we won't
be talking about this on the trophy room
a place each and every brother that was
a no-no proud so if we're so for most
like we say on the trophy room we put we
love all the consoles might my co-host
bought his first Xbox this November god
bless him
and so when I look at something like
this where it's allowing PlayStation
players to go outside the realm and go
into other ecosystems to play there and
experience PlayStation games that's
awesome we've had remote play on on the
Android and iOS for almost a year now so
that's not that's not new but the one
thing that I have to think is this is
not Sony going oh what does what to Phil
do and then like writing in there
companies are working years in advance
so PlayStation some guy named Jeff had
it had had an idea one day and they're
following suit with that you saw it with
guy Kyle when they announced the
PlayStation 4 that Sony had an idea of
what cloud gaming was going to be how
did it end up being the correct one no
but we're also seeing Phil Spencer have
his way of hey this is what we think
services should look like so right now
what PlayStation is looking at is they
have this service they've had this
service that has offered six hundred
plus games but no one's buying it and so
why aren't they and they're looking at
what their competition is doing right
where they have a hundred plus games and
people are really excited about it so
they're looking at where they can take
the value of PlayStation on the go and
so when I take a look at all this stuff
this this is awesome like this is being
able to play on my being able to play on
my Apple TV if someone's using my TV
that's fantastic I love the number four
right here it's a slim / portable Dual
Shock controller yeah I think that's
where everybody's taking it I think even
Phil Spencer put out destiny oh yeah no
reason I look Chris but but bad that's
awesome
before gotta get to the crab an opposing
platform that they don't switch they are
asking their base do you want our
service on the Nintendo switch and
possibly Xbox what does that not strike
you as a dude for change so dispute it's
a huge philosophy change that's why I
really do like what Jim Ryan's been
doing so far from what we've seen him do
publicly it i I would love to see the
day where we're playing use of war on a
Playstation and we're playing Uncharted
on an Xbox where it is pay less and
there are these boxes that'll play these
games best but you can play these games
anyway and where PlayStation and Xbox in
Nintendo have become platforms and not
consoles that's what I'm that's what I'm
excited about so like what I see them
going hey what what about the switch you
know switch their their direct
competition they're they're taking a
look at ago
well alright let's let's let's see let's
dip our toe in it Microsoft's doing it
was prepared and all their again I hate
to do this I got it I got every iterate
a lot of the base a lot of the Sony base
would state there will never be a
situation where first party exclusives
are shared or like for example before
the the PC thinking horizon zero dawn
and stuff like yeah you know right now a
lot of people are still holding fast to
the day and a part and I get that but my
question is this is now Sony's
exclusives on an opposing plot that I've
never seen before it's dirty it's their
service okay so like if they're they're
looking at bringing PlayStation out to
more places I don't think that's
necessarily saying like let me backtrack
when I say Uncharted on Xbox one meaning
is PlayStation now is on Xbox where you
can play some of their PlayStation games
right and maybe that is like an
uncharted lost legacy or something like
that I'm not I'm not and I and I think
the people that do complain and they are
showing the gifts of like people are you
know the guys jumping off the windows
type of gifts of Sony HQ those are vocal
minority I don't think they may echo
most gamers I don't think most gamers
care about that so for me when I take a
look at stuff like this it gets me
excited I don't I personally want to
play my playstation games on my TV not
home I don't care about playing it on my
phone or anywhere else but like if
that's what you want to do in it it
allows people to experience your
ecosystem that's what PlayStation wants
you to do so what I'm seeing MLB the
show on PC when I'm seeing horizon
that's them extending their IP so that
more people can experience the
PlayStation ecosystem that's what I
think they want the most but you think
they want MLB on Xbox oh yeah dude that
they're back IP Prince them cash so MLB
probably approached them going hey man
listen we like you guys do great work
you know if this is legal
different yeah we like your studio we
understand that that product the fans
like it but we see Madden we see FIFA
and we want that can you give us that
and and Sony's probably going yeah all
right I don't think I don't get down a
later on type of situation right you
don't like working rumor says yeah we
sigit I to eating that that one ball we
want to know oh my god and no choice but
to just give it up either yes or no I
mean no I I think to me this raises more
questions for their future IP like like
spider-man what's gonna happen when that
contract runs out right isn't that
contract up already no no no they got a
couple of games one would assume yeah
you you you said that they Spider Man
wasn't a one-off game that Disney
actually my whole question yeah I don't
what's the session the the exclusivity
as far as length of time with spider-man
I'm holding you know with the insomniac
and the Sony deal doesn't even make that
number of public yeah I didn't didn't
know they did this no I don't believe
I've seen that contract that's one of
the reasons in virtual legality we
talked about the destiny Activision
contract because that's one of the few
that's been made public
yes because of that lawsuit between
Infinity Ward and Activision but no we
wouldn't know but you can take a few
things one of the things that happens
with Marvel's spider-man on the
PlayStation is that you have what's
called a jointly developed intellectual
property okay right so you've got
spider-man that's obviously Marvel's
spider-man has been around a while he's
Peter Parker he swings he dresses up as
a spider it's a thing and then insomnia
what you say yes you know it's a whole
if I have to go further we could talk
about insomniac who comes in and makes a
game out of that now that game that they
made is something new that isn't
Marvel's own specifically and the
license that they had in that contract
will say certain things about that thing
that came out of the
joint development effort who owns it
what they can do with it how long they
can do with it for and what happens to
it after the term of that contract ends
we're all guessing as to what that looks
like but in all likelihood because Sony
funded that that they paid insomniac to
make that sony has at least what we
would call of a veto right over uses
that they don't want to see probably all
speculative all guesses right but
chances are in that contract there was
also an extension term whether or not
that was usable by both parties whether
one party could just say yes you have to
give us these rights in the future it's
open question these licenses can look
very different but chances are Spiderman
hits X amount of dollars sold X amount
of units sold Sony has an option to say
yeah yeah we're gonna make it under one
of those is that cool Disney and Disney
says okay well we made money off a 13
million units with alright well it will
live with it sounds good Sony and and
that's how those contracts are built you
try to anticipate the future you try to
look at okay what's the really good
scenario what's the really bad scenario
when do we need a divorce when do we
need to re-up and chances are since
spider-man obviously broke all sorts of
Records was hugely popular if there was
a renewal term some kind of automatic
term that would have been triggered I
think all the rumors suggest that
insomniac is already working them too so
that license is probably in existence
and probably not markedly different from
what it looked like five years ago when
it was entered into so when I see when I
see Sony going and in taking the MLB
license and throwing it on Xbox throwing
it on what we can presume the switch as
well that's only just going okay listen
we like making money we want to continue
this partnership with MLB it's a deal
that favors both of us I don't think the
L will be the show is like a spider-man
which is going to sell systems off the
shelves okay bad bit yeah my question is
isn't that a change of philosophy
because this is the exclusive title this
is like having a Gears or halo and this
is making this completely grabs the
conversation that goes the way he was
guilty
what I'm seeing is the change of
philosophy is dramatic and this is just
happen soon as the change of leadership
so gym dance move Ryan is yeah I
understand that he's under a tremendous
amount of pressure to perform you know
and sometimes when you under this
tremendous amount of pressure to perform
when get out of lay down situations
present themselves because I understand
they said that we want more money yeah
now we can't we know how much we're
gonna make from you as a projection of
what you're gonna make for us we also
see that this can be put over here and
over here and this is revenue that we're
not getting now being that we're
allowing you to produce this and you're
doing a great job
talk about so you have some kind of
badge MLB voice continued part of a team
you must know how to play ball pun
intended but I think the pub was
intended I honestly feel that's
absolutely zero choice in this matter I
think it's the same kind of concept
right so we talked about Marvel and Sony
Major League Baseball is a third party
so they have their own wants and desires
that are associated with this it's very
possible that Major League Baseball said
hey we totally screwed up the 2017 World
Series can you save us and they said can
you put Major League Baseball the show
on multiple platforms it's possible it
was driven by that it's possible was
driven by Sony here's what I would say
about this I think this I think this
conversation is important for change in
philosophy yes but I would also qualify
the kind of branding we're talking about
mm-hm and this is somewhat opinion-based
this is somewhat kind of how I
personally feel about these things but
when you talk about a sports team or a
sports game I don't identify the show
with Sony like I identify Kratos with
like identify the last of us with zoning
for them I think moving the show out
even moving horizon to PC which I
actually think is a little bit more des
stranding decima and we could talk about
that at a different time if you wanted
but moving the show to Xbox moving it to
Nintendo I think there's a blanket kind
of everybody loves baseball whatever
that isn't necessarily yeah it's made by
Sony and yeah it's been selling Sony
consoles to baseball aficionados for a
long time but I don't know that it
necessarily says oh this is PlayStation
this is Sony so I think moving that out
is less of an existential threat to the
Sony brand value than saying hello
people Nathan Drake's on series X let me
talk for a second okay now I get what
you're saying on there you know they
don't see that as a more of an hurt to
their brand putting around the platforms
but I would be okay with that statement
if it was just like that game or just
MLB in that game but you know we've seen
all the Quantic Dream games they all
came because a PC Sony owns every one of
those IPs well so Quantic Dream's the
second party there's open questions
about exactly how those licenses well
how many of these situations have to go
before we realize it's a Sony thing
pushing for this it's not another
platform pushing for this it's possible
I'm not saying you're wrong I really am
not I'm saying that a confluence I mean
they own debts training and they let
that go to PC I gotta read this I gotta
read this super chair okay so there's a
phantom Kraken yourself alright big king
just imply Sony started taking and blue
pill the matrix references oh my god
continue thank you so much eloquent Lee
put that together and I'm so happy that
you followed the rabbit hole the whole
metaphor okay no so all I was going to
say is that yes mm-hmm a confluence of
events a confluence of license they like
the Quantic Dream license where it's
looks from the outside again speculative
that there probably was a funding
relationship that actually did release
all the Quantic Dream games back to
Quantic Dream as part of that license
that's what that looks like that's why
it all happens at once etc but I feel
like a big game store happening all
within like a year and a half to two
year duration I really feel like Sony's
the one pushing for these to come to
other platforms and I can we go from we
go from an error where there's none of
these games or no the majority of their
games if none are coming to the platform
to PC and then we go from straight from
that to all the Quantic Dream's are
going to epic game store des train and
they funded they own the IP that's going
to they don't only I mean they
definitely don't own destiny no they
aren't destroy they own the trade so
waste oh yeah both say they don't own
the IB they own the trademark they might
have married mark did on behalf of
Kojima Productions but I don't believe
they own the IP whoa all I'm telling you
is this says Saudi interactive owns the
trademark yeah but I'm pretty sure that
Kojima owns a good portion of that game
and it was probably all I could tell you
is what I could physically see here's
how that works right so kijima
productions makes death stranding and
Sony offers to do certain back-office
support for them so Sony's good at trade
marking things I mean that was probably
one of 300 they did that day I mean
that's that's how a company like Sony
operates so it doesn't surprise me if
they are the name on the trademark it
doesn't mean that they have full rights
to it and wasn't assigned to Kojima
either either way regardless of that
point I can't sit here and tell you that
you're wrong about whether Sony is
pushing this or whether it is simply the
way these licenses work I do want to
speak to what other people have said in
terms of X cloud dreaming and this all
philosophy is in my opinion Sony is
definitely the most traditional moving
forward definitely wants to sell a
PlayStation 5 under the TV but I will
also say Sony has for the last two
decades now being a company that dips
its toe into things that are realized
this I provoked on the Internet
you see that as oh they're copying or
whatever I'm not going that are but I
will say that I think they're smart
enough to say well the game boys made a
lot of money what if what if a
Playstation were portable and then the
PSP is born and they give it a shot and
maybe not as bad as Google but they tend
to ditch these things if they aren't
immediate over-the-top successes right
this is experimental this is what every
good business does they say okay we've
operated in this fashion for this long a
period of time and what are the
properties that we could have that
wouldn't be an existential threat to our
console sales where we can go test these
waters exactly look like with horizon on
the PC what'd it look like with the show
on Xbox if there year that the show
comes out of the owner you don't see
that bump in whenever that comes out
February March right on the station you
say ok maybe that is a problem for what
we just did right and we don't do it
again you know what you don't know yeah
and that's the thing too is like we're
sony's not doing this blind right
there's probably someone on the back end
groups of people on the back end
analyzing to make sure that this is the
best decision for PlayStation and
vice-versa for mo be the show no one's
doing this on a feeling I don't think
that's how business when we're here not
good so when we're talking about like
again MLB the show
leaving PlayStation and a change of
philosophy that doesn't mean it's a bad
thing so when we're talking about Jim
Ryan this is a man who has made the ps3
remember the ps3 the garbage fire that
that console was for the longest time he
wasn't able to make that console
successful and dominant in your honor
and this is now the man now holding all
the pieces together so I'm not saying
he's understanding the future of what
gaming might be no I'm just absolutely
trolling what I say is this right I say
that the philosophy had to change and on
for a couple of companies to the people
that they had in positions of power
wasn't particularly
how can I say it uh agree and agreement
with said change the Reggie fils-aime as
well and I mean I believe that these
individuals are stood on a square and
they were you know they had to be
removed or they left on their own cause
because - because they're not listen one
monkey don't stop the show
all right and no point in time or is
anyone bigger than the shield you know
is anyone bigger than the company so
what happens is when you're not in
compliance with the company you can be
replaceable move with somebody that is
in compliance with what we're trying to
do going forward because if there's
money on the table to be made and you're
a company that brands yourself on making
money like every other company in the
world then why wouldn't you pursue those
opportunities that are 42 yes absolutely
no Shawn Layden when he left he was
president of the first party studious he
wasn't president and PlayStation as all
right I just referenced I don't want to
lose our overall point which is remote
play sorry right so I want to get back
on esos tell you know when you hear
about these surveys that Sony is doing
specifically with switch I want to ask
you try about it so you try to bring
this for two hours we have to get back
up focus so that is it with this news
one what do you think about it - if this
is the direction they want to pivot do
you think Nintendo would be in
compliance with such a thing of Robo
play on the switch well so this kind of
it's more of a market research thing to
me where they're kind of just putting
the feelers out there you know seeing if
people are at people I don't even know
if we're serious about it but they want
to know what the fans think you know
like in terms of Microsoft bringing
their games to switch you know minecraft
actually sells more more on switch than
it does on xbox and
and that was even before that they
bought the company um you know so that
kind of relationship is a little
different um you know in terms of
cuphead and and what's the other one or
a you know or ease more first party yes
um kind of I think they own the IP I'm
not sure and that's really more like you
know Microsoft and Nintendo have a good
relationship
I don't think Sony and Nintendo I don't
think so Nina teto I don't know this is
new and that's why I like Microsoft and
Nintendo are more willing to play ball
because you know Nintendo opens up Japan
to Microsoft when they wouldn't sell
anything in Japan
um so that relationship is actually very
beneficial Nintendo and Sony compete way
more than Sony and Microsoft do um
they're competing in Japan they're
competing in the US and then that
relationship is a little bit more
contentious you know really give you a
hypothetical as of said survey let's
just say now PlayStation base is an
overwhelming agreement to bring remote
play to the switch and they bring this
back up top do you think as a result
even though this this relationship has
been contentious in the past but they're
in the business of making money do you
think that they would approach the
Nintendo and and and and possibly try to
to make something happen in that regard
as far as will they be an app on the
device in the future I have to see to
believe it um you know about remote play
right it's a hard thing to actually see
the sales through that's a little bit
different than some games past right if
Microsoft were to approach Nintendo on
that you could share those that money
remote play is essentially just a
function yes so that's that's harder to
convince Nintendo of so you have to have
Sony approach them Nintendo has to give
permission and then that the question
becomes why does Nintendo give
permission in that scenario right well I
think that's why I the survey is is a
little bit ambiguous because I when I
hear half of the things that they want
to do with remote play have them thinks
that when if and when the place issue
files revealed or somewhere down that
down the road
remote play in PlayStation now is going
to look very much different
remarketed that's why I really think
that this is it's vague on purpose I
really do think this is more PS now that
I agree how you steal them up that's
what I would say like to me this is like
almost like king we call it the Trojan
horse so to speak with X cloud and
gamepad yes we're not gonna tell you
what our ultimate intention is but let's
put some tea music I get speculation
yard trader song no1 I have no
information or information that's great
tea leaf we know that they are working
with Microsoft with the azure cloud
right yeah that is going to be their
backbone moving forward they have that
agreement right
we know PlayStation now has become more
sleeker more competitive from a price
standpoint they now have some exclusives
on there right so who is to say Sony may
say look if we repackage PlayStation now
include remote play in the PlayStation
now pack similar the way X cloud is
doing with game pass game pass ultimate
and so forth and then say hey this is a
package our games with this surface on
your platform and again we know Ryan
seems to be very in the in the idea of
putting his games other places I mean
we've seen the PC stuff happen you know
I wouldn't be surprised if something
like that would I will purchase
PlayStation now yesterday they change
the philosophy to a more palatable more
palatable beverage from myself right I
will definitely drink said beverage with
no problems at all I will be drinking
the kool-aid this up you don't want to
wait for my um my switch to do right
good game pass then I'm loose then I'm
loose I know I went out movie in the
streets with my my eyes which running
down the streets playing gamepad I would
it break it back to stealth though take
so he can give us it to reality now if
they represent that in that package
though do you
the dough would at least have their ear
open maybe we could work with Sony yeah
if it benefited them yes
would would Nintendo reciprocate and do
something for Sony never it's not even
that it's just like they're both like
you know antennas number one in Japan
Sony's trying to be number one I think
that is the key reason to because you
know that low-key upset Sony they
probably never came out openly say that
but you know they that's their their
native constant so they're why would
they be bull willing to work with
Microsoft babe place T I got it why do
you think because they're nice Microsoft
yeah I think Nintendo sees Microsoft has
less of a like a direct threat right um
you know they're a lot of the genres of
game are different and you know but and
Microsoft isn't salad you know the
consoles aren't selling that hot
anywhere but um but and honestly be the
key is minecraft
but before Microsoft bought minecraft
minecraft was doing crazy numbers on
intend oh platforms and then once
Microsoft bought mine at that point yeah
are they gonna take it off so that
opened the door to you know maybe if we
put this on and you know that opened it
started the conversation go away even
yeah Xbox Live on Nintendo switch with
with that functionality achievement down
and everything hey bad bit yeah is that
a time fighter you got flame in fly
number oh yeah yeah it's a little it's
just a little like party thing yeah I
love it
ban my screen to salute our fire
back back on top that's all I was just I
was just surprised by that but if I
could expand on that for just a second
as well please is yeah when it comes to
Nintendo and Sony's relationship it is a
lot more tension when you seem intend oh
if if you're looking at if you're if if
if I ran intend up that's a dagger oh
I'm looking at Xbox is like hey listen
Xbox sells dozens of consoles in this
country they're not a threat to us if we
put their platform on our device we can
only profit you know we'll get home law
in there some type of profit sharing
where both parties can be you know
comfortable with where Sony what we do
yep let's go let's have a case of crab
as YouTube let's go where Sony is now
that it technically is an American
company at this point that's where the
headquarters is they are still there
history is in Japan it is still back in
the 90s with that tense relationship
with Nintendo and that is a way less
likely thing to see but at the end of
the day businesses or businesses they
don't work off of emotions they work off
of buku cash and that's what's gonna
probably motivate everybody I think we
got too super chance for did we get the
super chat from Victor Gordon 1/4
Joffrey there I think that's what's his
name that made God wore one there has
been a huge restructure in Sony
Playstation most of the former are gone
also the new CEO said to be more
saturated Nadella like yeah alright
again our boy fish you're on sale with
the slander today with Nintendo because
Nintendo is the link you and Sony is the
she Ryu with the board of combat
references competing and heating claims
Xbox is just in the middle eating pop
yeah I'm not the biggest familiar with
more confident that like scorpion and
yes you gotta make things simple for me
fan and so I know what's going on
[Music]
next time say scorpion or sub-zero don't
make me think this news was different to
me I must admit King I was definitely
surprised to see you know even just a
reference by Sony you know in a survey
base it definitely did get in the water
dipping a toe like like hold would say
just to see what the feedback from the
base would be you know me personally I
love verbal play I love using my feet or
more plays so I think the switch would
be a perfect like I already told you
this for our form factor how I feel
about that you know and it just comes
down to what's tell said you know with
Nintendo allowance No Fee give me a lot
of confidence
I mean wall because I mean I do surface
like this for a living for these let's
go you know and a lot of times though
though honestly they'll put questions
it'll put together questions just
because you know they're just curious
and there's no real like super um you
know they really wanted it but you know
they're just curious yeah yeah I mean
and then Tony yeah I know it's true it
would be different if it actually
happened and right now we're talking
about a survey absolutely you know
there's big gulf between them putting
out a survey and then actually doing it
I'm gonna be shocked I mean you know
right now no use being suspect with us
which early
and you know does their their surveys
you know what systems would you like
their their games to be on in the future
and they'll have all the systems but
they have no intention of putting any
other games on xbox they never have
so it's like they put it on there just
to see okay so you swipe right at the
end of the day when it comes to that
it's always nice to have as much
information as possible regardless who
you're going to use it or not they know
now fair enough let's move on last thing
we'll fly to as we're running a little
bit um listen man I fall in order has it
changed again
yeah so what I want to talk about just
make this a quick response cuz obviously
we talked like an hour and a half almost
the entire podcast about this which I
first often want to say a lore kognito
in no way shape or form er you'd bring
the switch into this conversation but
you know with the the the massive
success that um the the game Star Wars
fallen order was apparently it's like on
the high up of what their expectation
was like they never thought it would
sell like this and what the promotion of
van't Vince or Vance I don't know Lord
Lord Vince but whatever I mean you
trying to say so you know we what I want
to ask the realm what I want to bring to
the lords is do you think that with how
well the game did how well apex did how
well titanfall did for them maybe not
necessarily sales wise but you know
being a more of a diverse in the fact
that they bought their company do you
think that's respawn is changing the
whole philosophy of how EA does business
oh no no so there's a couple things
going on here for me so we'll see if I
can make enemies of the rest of the
points on this answer so I like
titanfall just fine titanfall 2 I played
a couple games of apex Jena fall in
order in my opinion
therefore is a success primarily because
of the wasteland of single-player Star
Wars activities that has been afforded
to fans of that brand for a lot and so I
like Jedi fall in order I especially
like the ambition and what they were
trying to achieve in that particularly
these minutes that trying I think that
their reach vastly exceeded their grasp
on this I think the technical months are
significant I don't necessarily think
the the level design is quite there I
certainly think the combat is wanting
especially when compared to something
like Sakura or or something else that
you might play from last year that being
said it's got lightsaber sounds it's got
laser bolt blasts and you say the word
Jedi a bunch so people do like it I
think it is a good move I look forward
to it having a leap in the future for
Jedi fall in order to like maybe an
assassin's creed 2 but for right now EA
is not about to change its gas focus
just because there was a moderate amount
of success for what is the biggest
intellectual property brand in the world
or was before Catherine Kennedy got done
with it here's the thing we're not just
talking about a 1 title we're not just
talking about - we're talking about
everything they have made has more or
less turned to gold for this company not
titanfall
- time for once sold well it wasn't a
what's - what was it but they posted
let's let spar a little bit here ok sure
absolutely that's what I'm here for I
hate what you're going at right my
question to you is that with let's look
at EA's philosophy prior you know cuz I
feel bad but you got to stop doing what
you do you think of me laugh their
philosophy probably seem to be very
multiplayer heavy very microtransaction
heavy you know they they actually I
believe one of the last earnings call
you know kind of say you know they they
weren't going towards the traditional
single-player experience
right and we do know thanks to the
Schreyer and the whole thing when anthem
you know that they were pushing
frostbite on a lot of development right
because they were not all right in-house
engine not pay any royalty fees and this
was the dre and we've seen the anthem
team the Bioware kind of struggle under
that engine right so my question to you
in reference now we bring it back to
Vince and respawn you know you have an
apex legends which is a free kind of
came out of nowhere game that is a
success right would anthem flop for them
then you have Jedi fallen order which is
really unconventional for ei in terms of
single-player no microtransactions and
using unreal which is something that
seems that no company that seems to be
exclusive to respawn under this banner
now you can make the argument yes prior
to respawn being acquired by EA they
were doing their own thing they were
separate on the outside they don't have
to capitulate to frostbite but we have
to say that what they're doing is kind
of beating to their own drum and against
what the corporate philosophy of EA was
prior and now as a result it appears
right that these got their Vince is
being rewarded by now being given the
head of dice right yeah yep and and stay
almost like I'm not gonna say they're
completely capitulated gonna change
their whole thing but to me it seems
like they're they're looking at what is
successful and I mean they only
projected you know that I believe a
fallen order to not even sell what they
said and they say yes six to eight and
then they hit ten euros and so in that
regard and by March thesis buy more and
now do you you not think that maybe his
cachet is at least rising in over thirty
so I think that's a separate question
from whether it should be so I mean it's
one of those things where businesses can
only react to the data and analytics
that they have in front of them and I
think you put out a nice sequence of
events for what his agent and his lawyer
should be saying I would agree was
boring with you would know right and
there's and there's our heads and
there's a tails I have this stuff and I
I would say you know look Star Wars fans
were desperate they had the last two
years Jan and and last Jedi fallen order
in Mandalorian thank God aren't the last
Jedi and everybody was happy that they
want and they went and they bought these
products and yeah like I said I actually
do appreciate the ambition of Jedi Order
I'm glad that it isn't just something
that has been done before I don't think
they did it very well but I think that
this was the first attempt at what was a
new kind of product for the the respawn
team in fact I think the genitive is
entirely hey no and that's that's really
about it I mean in terms I think I've
described it I've just started on my own
videos and the two holes are better than
one elsewhere as the most 7 of 10 game
of all ok Star Wars is an amazing
property Kathleen Kennedy you take all
the movies they've made even the sour
grapes they're still better than the
prequels in all honesty I think Vince's
influence has grown within the company I
think there's one of the board members
he has the same to say hey I don't want
my games running in front I think he
didn't use frostbite like who you have
companies that's made them billions
throughout the years like mad and
they're all using the frostbite exactly
multi-billion dollar corporation like yo
I'm using I'm using a little I'm not
using your wack so but the compounding
issue there is the third party right we
don't know what involvement Lucasfilm /
Disney had on that they are very hands
on with every use of their property
including but they don't usually do
anything yes frostbite yes and unreal
right but you know the the story that
came out of Kotaku but it was not during
the early days
it's not just that the fact that there
was no microtransactions in this game
when every single game EA's ever
published for like as long as I can
remember has had micro transactions
you're putting that on Zampella but we
also know that they got absolutely
bitch-slap by need for speed and
battlefront too and they were always
gonna walk that back in the next coming
years right and so you've got Zampella
yes making this game at the same time
but you've got an a very bad article
about frost by killing their development
in widget periodical I am getting killed
by micro transactions not just in Kotaku
but on their investor calls on what is
happening with your company right and
things along those lines you've got
Lucasfilm and Disney paying very
specific attention to what happened to
their brand goodwill with battlefront -
yes and that all leads into Jedi fall in
order I'm not saying any of that had any
specific indication on one thing or the
other in its development but I am saying
it's impossible to point at one thing or
the other from us sitting out here and
say bin Zampella was responsible for how
that game turned out of course you gave
up a choice with the $10 superjet thank
you so much great show I have to say
fallen order was a good but I would
rather see four son leaves three star
killers a better character to me and you
know what in a new saying that and me
reading this I'm and I'm reading it
because I felt the same way I always
loved star killer I thought star killer
was probably one of the most
underutilized characters inside the Star
Wars universe but then what I have not
read in the books
I even like Lorde like well he is
because he isn't he Bader's apprentice
right blue team said is all later that
he thought that stored star killer would
be as will could rival pebble team as
far as well Darth Sidious as far as
power but not intellect but anyway I
digress
I love the super chat I just wanted to
I really want
you were you were onto something and I
really want you to finish your point
because because I wanted to like jump in
on your point so for to go off a little
bit well Hogue has said yeah like
Disney's looking under their IPO for
microscope especially since things like
the last Jedi things like solo things
like bow front too and then with the
combination of the respawn acquisition
respawn beat has or goes to the beat of
their own drum
and you're seeing that payoff and you
are seeing Vince Impella I have a bigger
say at E Battier now does that mean no
Microsoft microtransactions whatsoever
no you see respawn games have them in in
truckloads like apex legends but it's
more about to me Vince trying to
diversify the portfolio of of some of
the EA properties at play right now I
think the success that we've seen from
respawn over this last year and just as
a company they've never made a bad game
I agree I'm which um see seeing that if
I'm a if I'm a chairman if I'm a
chairperson at EA I'm looking at that
going okay give this guy the reins of
some things
yeah he honestly knows what he's doing
and hold I think you're right - they've
been beaten and battered throughout this
whole entire generation PR why's that
they needed a win and this is the
closest thing they have to it and it's
great and it does show that QA and to
everyone around the a that this is what
consumers want from their company a game
that is fair right they want a game like
apex legends that's fair and they're
getting it right and they got it right a
bit with Apex listening to their
community over the last year of what
they expect from season passes or for
microtransactions used to be respawn
adjust accordingly and you're seeing
these far going hey now we're just gonna
give you a single-player focus game I
think EA is taking notice of that yeah
shoutouts tell 40k brother he had to run
he wanted to say you wanna be rules he
messaged me directly so salute stealth
40k thank you brother really
for sure bro that was love continued
kick I know you want to jump in on it
yeah okay so um I know no my thoughts on
it is absolutely correct in his
assessment I think it's a perfect storm
you got to shut all these people I think
it's a perfect storm when it comes to
Jedi forum in order because one you have
the the new Star Wars movie they're
released in December right so the sales
are carried through then you also had
the Mandalorian and you had other Star
Wars centric stuff that was being pushed
so Disney that that Disney brand pushes
because I saw a different advertisement
for Jedi fallen order all over the place
and you got to understand if I'm a game
past dude and I haven't been purchasing
games to be honest with your purchase
president he wore a game here and there
and I haven't been really going in my
wallet but for me to Fein for a game
right that means that one the marketing
fit to the thirst level is there and the
fact that we haven't had a single player
Star Wars game in a long time and yes I
would be like morning um a forced
unleash three but I settled for this
game I saw this game shadow this is no
this is the fact this is what we have
you don't have a diversified portfolio
when it comes to how many games is being
released within a year that you have
enjoy the choice you don't have a choice
so if you love Star Wars and you want to
play you're gonna get down you're gonna
play it you're gonna try it right so of
course they capitalize on that part of
me but being at ETA last year at e3 and
getting a chance to see that game behind
closed doors
I knew that game was special from the
moment it started yeah we saw that it
was something different yeah but it
lived up to that expectation of it now
is hope right that it's a seven yes is a
seven for hope yeah absolutely
I'm not claiming any authority over any
right but eating meaning being that my
thirst level from the Mandalorian you
already know that I'm down with the baby
Yoda syndrome all right you already know
and you saw me look at bad bits a TIE
fighter in the background this is the
reason why I wanted to go to bad bit
because I understand that he feels the
same way that I kind of feel when it
comes to the force it's gonna get an
eight to nine for me and now I know
there's there's just the Star Wars world
in general get you a couple right yeah
when this game came out I'll accompanied
with the Mandalorian it was like the
best week of being a Star Wars fan bang
because it was just from the starting
Mandalorian was average oh we gotta be
you gotta let me get this straight
ho can say that that's a seven edited
game in his opinion but I can't say a TV
shows average and I get the bus you know
people that put the bushes in for me
back because because you know Otto
cannot be in that bushes the only good
thing about that show was baby Yoda
nothing else he's trying to get a lot of
hate mail and I'm not gonna allow it
today you know the last question I have
we know how you feel about the rating
your rating of fallen Auto but again
hash tag keep a tick in the bush you
don't say but I just want to get back to
like I guess I guess what yet you know
do you see anything now changing do you
think it still would be status quo
moving forward with their philosophy do
you just say hey this that's a blip
that's really not gonna affect what EA
is doing you know long term well I have
to be honest with you I don't have a
great deal of faith in Electronic Arts
having their finger on the pulse and
figuring out what direction they should
move on any given topic in any given
year so I think that they will confess
this is EA hey this thing
it is hate I'll play what's good that
they release but it's you know few and
forthcoming I would say this wrong
though that's the funny [ __ ] yeah that
they yeah they accidentally stumbled
into successes in various time Jimmy you
know Mirror's Edge and dead space and
those kinds of things for a little while
we're pretty good it may ruin dead space
oh well I know Bobby Knight I bought a
lot of Electronic Arts games I've
enjoyed them in the feel like I feel
like you've lost some quarters it's not
true it's a I buy what is good and looks
appealing to me and Electronic Arts has
not been on that list as often as I
would personally like for no I'm joking
with you but I do yeah so I look at it
and say okay so Vince is now gonna run
respawn and dice first of all that's a
different role than he's had in the past
that's a management role yes of two
different companies having to put your
shoes in two different places I'm not
even sure if dices dice is still
headquartered somewhere okay so this is
Dyson North America yeah Eliane support
studio but they're creating alright so
but it's a different role and so you
always run the risk of elevating someone
to a role that's new and and hopefully
they succeed and I do think the more
Jedi fallen orders exist at EA the
better things are okay so it's a seven
out of ten for me right now
just like Assassin's Creed 1 was a 7 out
of 10 I see some good stuff in there
I hope that they can iterate on that and
polish it up for me because essence
creed was a was a decent game into was
probably the best when they made exactly
exactly so that's how I feel about those
kinds of things
is he a gonna change philosophically
ultimately know they've been chastened
by what Battlefront 2 did because they
went too hard too fast and they will
kind of figure out how to slow roll it a
little bit better that's gonna be their
job that's what they're trying to figure
out but at the end of the day I'm happy
Jedi fall in order exists I wish I liked
it more personally I love Star Wars
I'm very glad that the other people on
this panel love it as much as they do I
think that's great I want people to love
things I want to love everything
hard-earned cash on we can't we can't
forgive yourself I love pasta Lou
brother man we got to get you in the
round well fortunately girl wasn't here
we went to tease them hopefully it's
doing better
you don't say but I hope the drugs are
wearing off and it show is over you are
able to function now my plan became
strong so we go wrap yourself back here
we go we got to get out of here I got to
get to a Super Bowl so or you hold no
just said when you're down bro I would
check your DMS we will set something up
so I can pretty much love love what
you're doing out there so let's get this
Paul going new ILP pole with the
Nintendo switch having surpassed or
coming close to passing the Xbox for the
console sales do you think the switch
will continue its momentum once the Xbox
series X and the PlayStation 5 arise the
choices are a yes nothing is stopping
the switch train it's on its own lane
and will continue its accessible quality
exclusives King shakes his head and
discussed choice B no without a switch
probe switch will slow down and
eventually be less relevant when
next-gen arrives or C I don't care
because game passive remote play are
covered to the switch anyway
that's the one I'm already dead let's
get that Lois please rock the boat when
he goes up on Twitter
Lord hog games 40k and in honor of Lord
Nintendo guru please heal up so let's
start with Lord hope we can define
people find you what do you have going
on sir yeah absolutely well as you said
in your intro virtual legality now has
more than 7000 subscribers so we're very
happy about that on the YouTube channel
we talked about business and law often
with respect to video games often with
respect to pop culture diving into
things like you know did Blizzard breach
any of its contracts when they released
Warcraft reforged and things like that
which we hopefully have an enlightening
conversation on and hopefully one that
is helpful to those folks that are just
yelling into the void on the Internet
so if you're interested in those we're
into questions yeah the thing I like
about your shows for for dumb folks like
me that don't know law whatsoever you
make it a lot easier to come
well I very much appreciate that that's
the goal is to hopefully have a
conversation about it in plain English I
sometimes do better than other times but
those are the conversations we're having
on the youtube channel which is at
youtube.com slash old law and then I'm
also on Twitter all the time this is
where we first talked about Mass Effect
2 Lord Cognito and I on Twitter so if
you're interested in having those
conversations you want to get some
impeachment hot takes to go with your
various references to start control or
star control - that's where you can find
me at Hogue law on Twitter and thank you
very much for having me on the show
absolutely so good to have Holger -
realm it's always a pleasure - takes a
spicy it's always informative always a
little and again I cannot salute you
enough on your growth it is really
really cool to see people gravitating
towards your content and I just like
that I was there from day one so when
you get Hollywood just don't forget me
I'm bringing you Western oh my intros
yeah absolutely gotta do the intro and I
got a shout out to second Hulk
I got I got to speak to him - man I
would love to uh question him in the
realm if he's ever available oh that's
right yeah my brother is a developer at
high Moon and we
you know called - hugs are better than
one and he worked on Ratchet and Clank a
crack in time when he was at insomniac
he works on destiny when Bungie was
still affiliated with Activision I have
question of to get hopefully both hose
or the other hole whatever work schedule
eyes okay we'll do that thing now
definitely what I quit I have a lot of
questions especially resource management
it's far especially bloody I would done
some questions there so he will be able
to answer precisely half yes giving me
ammo to attack a cake I love it well
first let's just give a big shout out to
my YouTube dad then attended alright
everybody go to his channel sick with
the flu give him so much love out there
he works so hard to be crazy I couldn't
wait I know I know
rest in peace guru just in advance kendo
I may hate me but that's this podcast
could find me that big games over at
youtube.com slash bad bit games we
talked about all news and reviews and we
also have a podcast called the trophy
room a PlayStation podcast made by the
players for the players that's never
Thursday alright tunes on Google Play
Spotify all with my co-host my best
friend Kyle can talk about the latest in
grants and play Steve do we love all the
games and that's why we want to talk
about it today nice yo Sean capris say
looking for a new co-host soon rest in
peace salute to have a good to have your
bad but we will see you at
yes sir doing a little mediator that
would be fun man is gonna be great to
see you in Boston sir
and of course you already know the
regular Lords of the round table Lord
addict out here very combative today
abusing Hogue not letting him finish
attacking his thoughts oh good it's the
same as my day job well before you where
you could find me this is hogs Twitter
so definitely go follow him put his you
talk to it Bambi as well yeah I'm
putting all this in with a super
[Laughter]
technical following is a great great
content creator and his stuff for keg
definitely go follow him for all your
Nintendo I'm not even joking you follow
self k you won't need you won't need
anymore to Tendo news he's got his cocoa
research yes I would love to thank all
our lust Ria's guests that showed up to
the realm today hope is always welcome
here I love this law talk I love
everything about how cold is if I'm ever
in trouble hope I need you litigator you
have sealed it with me with their TIE
fighter flying inside yes beautiful
beautiful and also a shout-out to self
40k I know you can stay all the way
through but thank you so much brother
for coming through and
as we always do sorry you've just been
struck that's my bad rendition follow me
on Twitter where J Baris going at me
constantly and I got a beat them back
with a stick and caches that are loads
of game in that net we have a ton of
opinion pieces we have all types of
great reviews up right now and you know
attic is out here doing it up also you
can catch Kos you see all these little
statues or a little bit of place I'm
finishing this display case over here I
got another display case in the back
where US us venom is about to go in I'm
about to say spawn roof audience live I
got something coming for you guys um
also a couple of new statutes that just
came in the box this is back there got
some more coming in and we are waiting
the arrival of my new child baby Yoda so
which won't be into September but the
only good thing about the mandalorian
okay I mean hey some people like The
Witcher there we go and there you go you
listen guys ready she'll go watch power
there you go everybody the 200 that was
inside the the live viewing we
appreciate all the likes
we appreciate even the thumbs now for
you individuals that did not like switch
talk today or didn't like the Sony
slander that I gave you on a daily I
want to thank the chat you know we had
to think a 190 at one time you guys keep
coming here every week you keep coming
stronger and stronger every week when we
really do appreciate that it meant to
say pause everybody was fantastic they
get thanked everyone that came to Lord
Howe again Lord stop 40k and of course
there's Twitter's are in the chat but is
there in the chat please again again
thank everyone support Lords it gave me
dotnet man we're doing really good
seeing a lot of tremendous growth you
guys between the
articles it's been fantastic everybody
enjoy your Sunday I got a Super Bowl to
get to super party to get to
and if when I lose I will not be
accessible based on beverages that don't
listen everybody enjoy your Sunday we
will be back next week in the realm
peace